I want to announce some new tour dates
um these tickets will go on sale this
Thursday at 10 A.M local time November
9th in Norfolk Virginia
uh at the Chartway Arena November 10th
at Roanoke Virginia November 11th
Huntington West Virginia
November 15th Evansville Indiana
November 16th Pikeville Kentucky
November 17th Winston Salem North
Carolina and November 24th New Orleans
Louisiana down there at the UNO
Lakefront Arena and that is um
the day after Thanksgiving so that'll be
during Thanksgiving break uh all of
those new dates will go on sale this
Thursday at 10 A.M local time today's
guest is returning to the podcast he is
one of the uh most articulate men I
believe of our time between thoughts and
oration I don't know if there's I mean
he I don't know if there's anybody that
can um that can think and share as
eloquently as him uh we're really
grateful to be here in his home country
of Canada and to get to spend time with
him again on the podcast
um he is touring you can check him out
he has a new book that he's working on
he has uh books that will put in the uh
information below today's guest is Mr
Jordan Peterson
[Music]
[Applause]
people used to have those all over their
houses it wasn't a good idea especially
if they had dogs are we rolling nice rat
thanks man
that's my nickname is the Rat King oh
yeah
so that's kind of do you have a nickname
you know what a rat king is huh do you
know what a rat king is uh-uh oh my God
it's a terrible story this is a rat king
uh-uh well this is the theory now I
don't know if people ever did this so
imagine your village is full of rats oh
yeah okay so now you go catch 10 routes
okay you throw them in a pit
okay soon
there is one route
because he gets all the other routes
he's a champ
then you throw 10 more rats in there
soon there's one route you do that three
or four times then you take the
remaining rat let and you let him go
and soon there are no rats in the
village really
that's the theory wow so he it was like
the toughest of them all yeah and then
he learns to eat rats wow oh so you
teach them to cannibalize no we just had
that's a rough story eh Jesus yeah I
mean it doesn't have that sort of like
politics yeah that's true especially
these days I don't think it's for the um
I wouldn't say it's for children no it's
not it's not for children although it's
hard to tell he's not what's for
children do you see that movie up did
you ever see that yeah yeah yeah right
in the beginning the grandmother dies
and uh and it's just kind of like
shocked you I was like wow you know yeah
so but that's a good story I remember
when I was young if you got somebody a
hamster or a uh gerbil that's how you
taught him about death you know
it was usually like gerbil and then
grandparent was kind of like the
God the order you know the order that
things kind of expired in in a child's
life
um that's very terrible well welcome to
this uh Salem Witch Trials of Canada oh
yes yes I'm here on behalf of the um the
Ontario is it the cycle the psychology
department because no it's the College
of psychologists and it's confusing
you're on a trial right now you're under
yes it's essentially a trial you're
being brought up on you have to take
social media
re-education re-education from your
province is saying this is that right um
it's a it's a professional group but
they have delegated authority from the
provinces so there are regulated
professions okay and Engineers lawyers
Physicians psychologists social workers
teachers there's there's a few others
and if you're in a regulated profession
there's a professional body that governs
professional conduct to which the public
has access in case people misbehave and
so the Ontario College of psychologists
its College as in group professional
group rather than University and it's
the Ontario College of psychologists
that have decided to pursue initially 13
charges against me they dropped seven
why they dropped those seven is a
complete mystery as is everything else
they do
you can submit a complaint to the
College of psychologists online with a
form and so what's happened at least in
part is because that's become so easy
it's become weaponized by activists so
for example if you want to cause anybody
who's in professional trouble all you
have to do is submit a complaint to the
college the college
we'll look into the complaint every
complaint and then decide whether
they'll proceed now they're not supposed
to proceed if the complaints are
vexatious or you know just troublemaking
but they've decided that me complaining
on Twitter about Trudeau for example is
uh unprofessional and a disgraced is a
disgrace to the profession which is
essentially what I've been charged with
is being a disgrace to the profession so
it's trying to hold up what they presume
is some esteem of the prev of the
profession that's the that's the theory
and some Professional Standards and you
know I would say for decades that system
actually worked pretty well because the
people who sat on it weren't
ideologically adult and the public
wasn't using it in a weaponized manner
but that's changed completely and now
every professional in Canada and I
believe that to be true is essentially
without exception unless they're on the
far left
are completely unwilling to ever utter
any opinion about anything in the
political or their professional realm
especially in relationship to medicine
and psychology the Physicians now the
Ontario College of Physicians is
partnered with the Ontario College of
psychologists to go after me because
they're also afraid that if I was
victorious in this their idiot mid-level
bureaucratic power would be diminished
and so and I've had conversations with
many physicians in particular who've
told me flat out that they'd like to
publicly support me but they can't
afford the tremendous legal costs
and the lengthy Inquisition that's a
consequence or the possible suspension
of their license so so you're going to
probably have to go this alone in some
way uh I do have people who have
presented themselves as interested
parties on the legal side the there's uh
the Canadian civil liberties Union is
one of them there's a Justice uh uh CCF
I believe they're now they're going to
be irritated at me for not remembering
the name but I can't remember that at
the moment there's a number of groups
who are pro-free speech let's say who've
also weighed in on my side but the court
didn't take their concerns with they
they didn't make their concerns
Paramount let's put it that way yeah and
the judges so I appealed this ruling so
the ruling essentially is that
I have to take social media retraining
with a social media expert and I'd like
to make it very clear there is no such
thing as there's no profession yes like
The Wizard of Oz like who is it going to
be is it do you know the expert no I
don't that's correct no I've gone
through a couple of names but I don't
even know what defines you as a social
media expert and neither does the
college and they don't care you know if
someone presents themselves as a social
media expert that's good enough my sense
is that if you're a social media expert
you have a podcast with millions of
followers and you're doing just fine on
your own and you actually don't need to
work for an idiot bureaucracy but you
know that's just me right so now not
only do I have to be re-educated by this
social media expert but I have to do it
at my own expense which you know was
neither here nor there in some sense but
for an indefinite period of time wow
until I've learned whatever the hell
lesson I'm supposed to learn and I don't
exactly know what lesson that is
by their judgment right and so it's all
up to them so it's kind of this vague
thing that they've put you into and they
challenged you because they they were
upset at things you had said on Twitter
on Twitter no well okay they also and
maybe that that maybe this can happen
today somebody submitted
the entire transcript of my last
conversation with Joe Rogan as a
complaint partly because of what I said
about climate change now I am not a fan
of climate change models which I think
are
to call them flawed is to barely scrape
the surface but that isn't exactly the
point is what happens is you have
climate models that have really no
predictive validity they're about as
valid as the models that scientists use
to predict coveted death outcomes right
which tended to overestimate the
mortality probability by a factor of
about 10. they're not accurate and a
computer model is a hypothesis not data
it's a guess now you know it's an
intelligent guest or it can be depending
on how you model It Anyways on top of
the climate models there are even more
radically unstable economic models
saying you know that the consequences of
climate change will be catastrophic if
you look a hundred years into the future
it's like
nobody can make an economic fit 100
years into the future
period right period the end you can't
even look we can you can't even model a
stock six months down the road much less
than the world economy in a hundred
years it's Preposterous yeah I mean I
think there's been so much climate over
the years I think you'd have to take a
ton of things into consideration you
probably have to take a lot of things
into consideration that we don't even
really know
um well how can you imagine trying to
predict today's economy 100 years ago
like I can't even think about how we're
going to predict
what's going to happen economically in
five years given a rate of change but
our economic changes or patterns as uh
do they have as many variations as
weather patterns Yeah well yeah they do
partly because they're dependent on
weather and climate patterns right I
mean in some ways the economy is as
complex as everything okay because well
because you just don't know what will
happen if there's imagine there could be
imagine Yellowstone blue you know
Yellowstone it's Yellowstone I believe
that's on a super volcano it's a huge
volcano and if it blew it would be like
a you know it would wipe out a third of
the planet well that would have Economic
Consequences and so the the economy is
you can't model the economy in fact
that's actually why the free enterprise
system works to the degree it does
the free exchange because what happens
is that pricing decisions are made as a
consequence of local trades and that is
as good a model of the underlying let's
say reality that people are trying to
adapt to as you can possibly manage it's
partly why centralized governments can't
work okay they can't compute the load so
for example
in the Soviet times there is a central
pricing committee because they have no
pricing mechanism right they couldn't
figure out what anything cost because
there was no free market they had to
make 400 pricing decisions a day and
they had to do things like price nails
and it's like well
what's a nail worth yeah and the answer
is well
the market computes that and in the
absence of that answer well
there's no limit to the range of
potential value that a nail might have
like if there's a nail shortage that
actually turns out to be a really bad
thing oh pricing decisions are insanely
hard to make oh yeah I mean I think
yeah I mean it's funny they give you a
lot of nails when you buy them but I
think things could change you know I
mean you could go there and have to just
get one nail
um but so just so it would be a bad day
it'd be a rough day yeah but you'd have
to really use it wisely you would you
did yeah you'd have if you're gonna tell
me put it up you'd probably like display
it gold plated I used to have nails yeah
if you're gonna pin a tail on a dog you
better mean it that day huh
um but just so we stay on so so I stay
in this one frame of like so do you feel
like but they're so they're challenging
your things you've said on social media
right yeah well so do you think it's a
challenge of your free speech is that
what you feel like oh I the the court
that ruled against my appeal essentially
said that it was a free speech issue
okay and they said in their opening
argument that according to the Canadian
Charter of Rights which was by the way
instantiated by Justin Trudeau's father
Pierre Trudeau and Justin's regime is in
the process of absolutely gutting it
anyways I have a right to free speech
according to that Charter but and that's
the next sentence this very low level
bureaucratic institution has the right
to abridge that essentially as they see
fit which means as far as I can tell
that I don't have the right to free
speech at all and I should make very
clear
those colleges should be intervening
when a client or a patient right or
customer depending on the regulated
profession has been mistreated in some
manner by the person they're dealing
with okay the people that levied
complaints against me first of all most
of them don't live in Canada second of
all none of them were clients of mine
third none of them knew anyone who was a
client of mine they claimed harm that I
had done harm on behalf of other people
who they also didn't know so it's a
Witch Hunt really well and they also a
number of them also claim to be clients
of mine in writing in the complaint
they're not no they're not clients of
mine and clients of mine before I became
politically known let's say I practiced
as a clinician for more than 20 years
and I had zero complaints and I had zero
complaints levied against me at the
University too either at Harvard or at
the University of Toronto and the reason
for that was that I treated my students
my colleagues my co-workers and my
clients well all the time there was zero
problems but as soon as things exploded
around me politically well the people
who've weaponized the colleges have
taken that opportunity to go after me
and then the college which is nicely
Infested by radicals like almost
everything else in the west and
particularly in Canada are using this
opportunity to attempt to make my life
miserable but we'll see whose lives are
made miserable
wow
yeah do you feel do you do you almost
was there a part of you that kind of was
like excited about the car like not to
not to begin with like it's not ever
entertaining to face legal proceedings
yeah you have to be a fool generally
speaking to think that even if you're
the one loving a lawsuit you have to be
a real fool to think that it's going to
do anything but cause you a lot of grief
and misery like lawsuits are not
entertaining and I have quite a
pronounced proclivity to feel guilt and
I went through the like this has been
going on a long time off and on for
about six years but a lot of ruling just
happened right well the Court ruling
that denied my appeal just happened okay
yeah because I appeals to go through
yeah no the next thing they have to do I
either have to go through with the
training or they have they can drag me
in front of a disciplinary board and my
next move is going to be to say
hey bring on the disciplinary board they
film those wow I will put that on
YouTube
so if they want to make the case that
for example my objections to the trans
surgical mutilation of children
my I believe that to be wrong like I
believe it's actually a crime against
humanity the reason I believe that by
the way is the U.N definition of crime
against humanity one of them is
involuntary sterilization my sense is
that if you're a medical professional
and you sterilize a child that's
involuntary sterilization because they
are not qualified to give qualified
consent informed consent as anyone with
any sense recognizes yeah they can't
even go on a field trip without getting
uh signature right or you know what I'm
saying yeah yeah right so they can yeah
they can't go on like a yeah there are
there are hospitals now genital field
trips yeah well there there are
hospitals now when they inform the
children of what's going to happen for
example if they castrate them for
example
um they tell them the girls
um obviously they're not castrating the
girls they're just doing double
mastectomies and sterilizing the girls
but they tell them that they might have
to have their eggs stored because this
is going to interfere with their
fertilization and if they ever want to
have children well that'll be what
they'll have to do it's like well you
know every 12 year old is capable yeah
no kidding no scared thinking about it
it is absolutely despicable I believe
that the people who've done this should
be in prison for the rest of their lives
so do you think no excuse speaking up
against things like that are some of the
reasons why they're kind of oh I think
that was the primary reason well I I
tweeted something out about Elliot page
Ellen Page yeah remember we're in
trouble now we're already in trouble
trouble yeah I said that I said do you
remember when Pride was a sin and when a
criminal physician cut off Elliot Allen
Page's breasts and uh that got me kicked
off Twitter but that was also one of the
tweets that was complained about you
know and I had friends I actually did a
whole YouTube video on this uh I had
friends who kind of upgraded me for
being a little harsh and we talked it
over on YouTube for about 90 minutes and
I don't regret it at all in fact I think
that in the intervening year since that
Tweeter so the tides turned very firmly
in a direction that indicates that my
suspicions were more than warranted you
know a lot of the European countries
that were all on board with this
so-called gender affirming care have
reversed their stance right including
the Netherlands where this protocol this
hypothetical gender affirming miserable
statement because it's such a lie where
that protocol first emerged the Dutch
have realized that this is a bad idea
they've realized it in the UK and in
Norway and Sweden in France and they're
pulling back like math now the Americans
and the Canadians are still thinking
this is just a fine idea but but it's
not well it's probably still a bit
there's probably still people trying to
do the do the balance sheet of what is
the value of it you know in America I
mean a lot of things come down to kind
of like you know what can be profited on
it yeah well that's for sure but do you
feel like in Canada they are just
because Canada is kind of like a pat
it's I don't want to say it's a passive
place but it's like a it's kind of like
a uh
I don't know it was passive the word do
you think I think passive is a
reasonable word compared to the excited
States of America let's say okay that's
very fair right well and I think to some
degree look you know our constitution
originally your your system is
predicated on the idea of like right to
life liberty and the pursuit of
happiness and our constitution was
predicated on peace order and good
government right it's a very different
view of what constitutes an appropriate
Society right that the basic doctrines
of your country are more entrepreneurial
and adventurous and I really think you
can see that in the difference between
the two countries and more individual
and more yeah and more libertarian and
and more entrepreneurial and
um you can see that in the temperaments
of the two countries and actually things
worked very well in Canada I would say
till about 10 years ago 15 years ago
something like that because our
institutions
all of our institutions were
conservative in the in the best sense
right they were reliable and stable and
predictable but they also honestly did
what they were supposed to do and that
was true even of of say government
sponsored media agencies like the
Canadian Broadcasting Corporation the
CBC which is sort of our equivalent of
PBS but what's what most much more
dominant in Canada and our higher
education institutions worked and our
political parties were pretty
predictable you know we had the
conservatives
and they were the party of big business
and everybody knew that we had the
Liberals and they were the natural
governing party and they were centrists
kind of like more conservative Democrats
that's about where I would put them in
the political distribution then we had
the Socialists the NDP we still have
these three parties and they were
essentially a labor party and and made
up of Union people and that's all blown
into bits now and and every those
parties for years played their roles and
they played them honorably and honestly
and everyone knew what they were getting
and that's completely turned upside down
Trudeau's Liberals are farther left than
the Socialists and in fact the
Socialists have been reduced to a parody
of themselves in Canada a few months ago
I wanted to sell something online I
wanted to sell a batch of knives that I
had at the house
and I was trying to get rid of them I
didn't know what to do I had no idea
where to get started that's why I'm glad
that I found Shopify that's right
Shopify is the Commerce platform
revolutionizing millions of businesses
worldwide whether you're a garage
entrepreneur or IPO ready Shopify is the
only tool you need to start run and grow
your business without the struggle
that's true Shopify puts you in total
control of every sales channel so
whether you're selling satin sheets
uh knives
or anything else uh you can sell them
from shopify's in-person POS system and
once you've reached your audience
Shopify has the internet's best
converting checkout to help you turn
them from browsers to buyers that's
right Shopify Powers 10 of all
e-commerce in the US and shopify's truly
a global Force Plus shopify's Award
winning help is there to support your
success every step of the way you hear
that sound it's the sound of a sale
you're missing out on because you're not
selling on Shopify and what does it
sound like with Shopify
that's much better start selling with
Shopify today you just need to go to
shopify.com
t-h-e-o that's
s-h-o-p-i-f-y.com slash Theo to take
your business to the next level today
liquid IV if you want to get hydrated
and stay hydrated you want to you want
to drink something make it feel like you
drank something
liquid IV can help they're the number
one powdered hydration brand in America
they're also now available in sugar-free
that's right
years in the making hydration multiplier
sugar-free uses a proprietary zero sugar
hydration solution with no artificial
sweeteners
with three times the electrolytes of the
leading sports drink plus eight
vitamins and nutrients for everyday
Wellness liquid IV hydrates two times
faster than water alone oh boy
they've got some great flavors white
peach green grape and lemon lime
one stick of liquid IV in 16 ounces of
water hydrates you two times faster and
more efficiently than water alone be
damned water be damned
real people real flavor real hydrating
now sugar-free grab your liquid IV
hydration multiplier sugar-free in bulk
nationwide at Costco
or get 20 off when you go to liquid
iv.com and use code Theo at checkout
that's 20 off anything you order when
you use promo code Theo at liquid iv.com
do you feel like you've been picked a
lot because you're like a loud I I don't
I don't mean this disrespectful you're
like a loud Canadian right you're like
the probably the loudest Canadian since
like Celine Dion probably right but in a
total different like you know but you
you know Canadians are usually kind of
more past I guess not really I mean
Howie meant I mean there's a lot of
Canadians that are verbose yeah right
there's a Canadian there's a Canadian
but maybe it's not a challenging of like
the status quo I don't know what I'm
trying to say I'm just trying to wonder
why are they Canadian Comedians and we
have a good comedic tradition yeah and I
would say to the degree that Canadians
Arlen Williams like a lot of great
comedians Jim Carrey yeah yeah lots lots
of the whole SCTV crowd like there are a
lot of really great Canadian comedians
and and that's that's a long-standing
tradition and they can be pretty
viciously satirical the trailer park
boys are a good example of that and I
think they're absolutely bloody
brilliant that
um for for scripted comedy they're
scripted comedy is remarkable but I do
think that Canada is a country where
being what they call it tall poppy
syndrome if you're the poppy that grows
up above the rest then you're the first
one who has his head cut off that's what
I'm trying to say yeah that's true of
many countries but it's particularly
true of Canada because it kind of it
makes it more about you than about what
what or maybe not you're making it more
about you but if you start to like yeah
Canada just wants to be almost like we
were here yes we want to be able to fit
into a space but it's very manageable by
us yeah well that's what it seems like
and it goes over well like I mean yeah I
find the peace that I feel in Canada
when I'm here the genuineness in
people's eyes that I see
um even people that look mean come up to
you and then they're nice they just
looked a little mean you know like it's
like
um it's it's really really wonderful I
love Canada I love the people here but
yeah I think I'm just wondering why it
is your like why are they challenging
you for free speech like what is that
well I think I'm also I'm also a
reasonably effective opponent say of the
current Administration generally and I
think that definitely I I don't I'm not
trying to imply that they're directly
complicit in what's happening to me
in relationship to the college because I
don't believe that to be the case but um
I also don't think that I'm a friend of
anyone who is a friend of the current
liberal Administration in Canada and
these judges for example they were true
to appointees and also they were true to
appointees with a long history of
essentially left-wing activism so that
has awesome so that also well and that
this is another terrible thing that's
happened in Canada is that our courts
have become and our legal system have
become politicized and that was never
the case in Canada not in any real way
we had enough sense for a very long time
to keep politics out of the Judiciary
out of the education system out of the
media our country wasn't politicized we
had political parties and everybody knew
where they were and that's where we had
our discussions and they went quite well
and apart from that outside of that
things were not politicized but now
in Canada and this is the case in the
west more generally virtually everything
is radically politicized and yeah do you
think you guys caught that from the West
in a way do you think that that's a
negative thing that happened that came
over from there I think that we
contributed that to a large degree and I
think we did that back in the 1980s
Canada has always tilted towards group
rights yeah and that's what it feels
like yeah yeah it feels like it's for
the common good well part of the reason
for that was that we had to bend
ourselves into knots to keep the country
together because there was so much
tension between the French and the
English and Canada and it's so cold you
got to huddle up well yeah here well um
that also may be why this place is
somewhat more collectivist let's say
than the US I mean winter here is no
bloody joke and you know everybody
pushes their neighbors out of snow banks
in the winter no so I think that 100
yeah you've got to really be a team do
you think like so so yeah I think what
I'm trying to think more about is just
like the challenge like about Free
Speech right like about how it's being
challenged everywhere it's going to be
really strange if those people get you
in front of a board they're not going to
do that oh I don't think they have a
choice actually I think what they'll try
to publish it you know they'll they'll
try to keep it secret but that ain't
going to happen they should you have to
do pay-per-view yeah no kidding no
kidding absolutely absolutely I know I
know when you want to be your corner man
if there's rounds I want to come in
between rounds well you were asking if I
was looking forward to it and like I
said
um you have to be a fool to look forward
to legal proceedings but I went through
all 13 of the charges over Christmas
last last December you know which was
not a very pleasant three days because
you never know when you have hundreds of
pages of paperwork which I had to go
through you never know if you
you never know when you might have done
something stupid that's going to catch
up with you you know and everybody has
stupidity in their past and so I was
pretty damn apprehensive when I went
through all the paperwork but when the
more I delved into it actually the the
better I felt because not only did they
make terrible procedural errors like
going ahead with the complaints of
people who literally claimed falsely in
writing to be clients of mine and I
think six of the complaints are like
that but it's just so utterly
preposterous I mean two of the things
they complain about are literally
criticisms of of Trudeau and like if I
can't criticize a standing prime
minister in my own country there is
something seriously wrong one of them
was his chief of staff one of them was a
city councilor
um one of them was the trans issue that
we discussed one of them I criticized to
uh Sports Illustrated for presenting a
very obese cover model and I said that
as far as I was concerned she wasn't
beautiful and that no amount of tolerant
of authority compassion was going to
convince me otherwise and the other
thing that the other reason that I think
Canadians got mad at that and I think
people in general is that they think I'm
being mean you know and you should be
nice and first of all I'm not exactly so
sure that you should be nice all the
time I think we as a culture have got
ourselves into an awful lot of trouble
by being a little bit too nice like I'm
not so sure I'll give you an example of
that so Nicola sturgeon who was the
former prime minister of
Scotland said any man who says that he's
a woman is a woman you think well that's
pretty nice if the guy wants to be a
woman well we can just go what harm
could it do yeah and then and then the
serial sexual
Slayers in prisons decided that maybe
they were women
because maybe then they could go to
women's prisons and you know if you
don't think that a Serial sexual killer
will manipulate His Image to get access
to women you are a complete blithering
bloody idiot and of course that's
exactly what happened in Scotland and so
sturgeon was called out on her
pathological compassion and that was one
of the things that led to a resignation
it's like
tolerance Beyond a certain level is 100
percent absolutely incontrovertibly a
vice and when tolerance has got to the
point where it's a vice then it's time
to not be so nice when you say advice
what do you mean
um oh that that's a very good question
you know what it what is advice exactly
well a vice is a pattern of behavior
that if indulged in especially
repeatedly leads to nothing but negative
consequences even by the self-def
definition of the person engaging in the
vice and so look excess alcohol use
tends to be a vice yeah well why okay
how do you diagnose alcoholism as a
pathology well the first thing you do is
you look at amount and frequency let's
say but that's not enough
it has to be a high amount frequently
that causes substantial disruption to
one or more important domains of life so
if you're wondering whether you're
drinking too much you think well is it
compromising your health are your
friends starting to object have you got
in trouble with the law is your wife mad
right exactly exactly so so is the
behavior starting to produce negative
consequences even by your definition or
perhaps even more importantly by your
definition then you'd say well any
behavior that
tends to be quite entertaining in the
short term but let's say not so good
socially or in the long term that's a
vice and we all know that you know
there's lots of things like drinking is
a great example it's an absolute bloody
blast especially if you like alcohol but
you know when I was a kid I used to
drink Fair bit and I quit when I was
about 24 25 maybe a little later than
that and uh you know I was out three or
four times a week having a just a fine
time drinking beer whiskey yeah usually
beer I like beer a lot but I but
whatever was available fundamentally
anything wet yeah yeah and um at some
point especially as my professional
career developed I realized that
I realized essentially and this is also
when I started when started my my
permanent relationship with Tammy I
thought you know the only thing I only
time I really do things I regret is when
I'm drinking yeah you know if I'm and
same yeah well that's the thing well
that's a vice man it's like it's not
good for you and it's actually not good
if you're trying to aim up like you
couldn't do what you're doing
now how old are you you die at 27 like
you would have died at 27. just most
people die you know and they die from
vices generally you know you telling me
that last time one of the last times
that we spoke so so there's a lot of
challenge to your free speech you're
saying that things you've said that
they're mean right but they're not it's
like you know you're supposed to now
you're supposed to say that there's
nothing sexual about drag queen Story
Hour it's like it's mean to say that
it's like
there's nothing sexual about grown men
with false breasts dressing up in
negliges which are clearly sexually
provocative and reading to Children
there's nothing sexual about that yeah
okay no I think I'll burn my eyes out
with a sword it's like no I'm afraid
there's something sexual about that like
yeah and to me yeah it would be I mean I
I think it would be
that would be a lot to consume as a
child and understand you know it would
feel like there would be some barrier to
entry between me and that if I were a
child
yeah yeah trifle well you know it's a
part of complexity to throw at a child
yeah it just seems like a lot of
complexity to throw at a child you know
um yeah yeah
um so so I'm just thinking mostly about
free speech like do you feel like free
speech is becoming more or under Fire or
do you feel like that we're just uh no
it's way more Under Fire look I talked
to I was in Greece a while back and I
met a professor there from the Kennedy
School of government right which was for
decades and even now is one of the
preeminent
higher education institutions for the
discussion of political issues and
political philosophy and he told me flat
out that his colleagues can no longer
feel comfortable expressing their
genuine opinions to their students and I
mean that's that's game over right
because
the only thing you have as an educator
and certainly as a psychologist is and
as a physician a lawyer for that matter
is your handle on the truth well is
civil law one of our problems with that
because people just want somebody to
hear something they don't like they sue
there's always like a lawsuit against
um a police department a university it's
just like we didn't like hearing this
they shouldn't be saying yes then it's a
lawsuit and then once it becomes a
financial burden they can't afford you
literally cannot afford to do it anymore
like if we have three more teachers
speak out this year then that's going to
be all of our endowment or whatever for
the spring and now we're going to be out
of business yeah well it's definitely if
the advantages on the accuser is for the
accuser constantly then everyone no one
can speak anymore right that's what it
feels like and we have weaponized all
sorts of systems of accusation and we
haven't
built equivalent systems of defense and
that's that's a very bad idea and I
think I think a lot of this is actually
fostered by social media because you can
and do you and it's funny because in
some sense this is also what I'm being
accused of doing you know in in some
sense you can say things on social media
that you could never say to someone face
to face and not only can you get away
with it you are rewarded for it and
that's a very very very very bad idea
now I would say in my own defense is I
don't do this anonymously right if I
have something to say I'm going to say
it and I've gone after the anonymous
online troll demons and I called them
troll demons for a real reason you know
because well they're trolls obviously by
cliche but why demon and the answer is
is because
if you're using a computer you're not
exactly human anymore you're a machine
human hybrid you know and if you're just
some resentful son of a sitting in
the basement perturbating about how
miserable your life is and trying to
spew as much venom as possible you can't
do a damn thing down there by yourself
right you're completely powerless and
you deserve to be because you haven't
done a goddamn thing with your life but
if you have a computer at hand you can
multiply yourself hundreds of thousands
or even millions of times you can do
that on Twitter right right and you can
pollute the entire domain of political
discourse and so I I believe we have
disinhibited the Psychopaths online and
that's that's a recipe for disaster but
there's no way to figure but I don't
know if there's a way to like fix that
you know it feels like
um there's no like unless you had to
have like the exact unless you couldn't
be anonymous online right yeah which I
mean that was one of the problems that
happened with social media everything
developed so quickly there's been just
no jurisdiction over any of it yeah I
mean it's just and so it's but then
we'll news outlets will use it as if
it's like Goss Like It's like factual
information you know like they'll use a
tweet from somebody in a basement
somewhere or in a birdhouse or whatever
if somebody could be in a birdhouse and
they'll say oh well this guy you know
Ricky birdhouse 40 you know he's pissed
off about this and it's like who gives a
yeah you know that guy's never he's
never done anything in his life why
should he be able to suddenly challenge
someone who's worked their butt off to
have like a a stance or a space but then
also does that person deserve to have a
voice still you know like well there's a
bunch of problems you know we felt that
democratizing the public forum was going
to be a good idea you know and you can
understand that what do you mean
democratized well so that everybody
would have a voice okay right okay again
by the same token you know you own your
house and no dimwit off the street can
just come into the middle of your house
and not only yell at you but also yell
at you and all of your friends
simultaneously yeah but he can do that
online right and that's not good there's
no barriers and so and the problem with
that is that and this is back to this
problem of Tolerance is that there's
about three percent of the population we
know this cross cross-culturally who who
have dark tetrad personality features oh
yeah yeah yeah yeah so they're
Machiavellian which means they're
manipulative they're narcissistic which
means they want unearned attention
they're Psychopathic which means that
they have no empathy for other people
and so that was the dark Triad
originally but they had to add another
lovely Dimension to that which was
sadistic they positive Delight in the
pain of others and we know that the
online troll types especially the ones
that are Anonymous are much more likely
to have those four sets of personality
characteristics that's about three
percent of the population now that three
percent of the population
has posed a danger to the Integrity of
individual and Society since the
beginning of time like the entire
criminal justice Enterprise is devoted
to keeping that small percentage of
people under control so like one percent
of the criminals commit 65 percent of
the crimes right it's a specialization
and that small percentage of people is
so dangerous as well that if they get
the upper hand they'll tell they'll tell
they'll tear everything down partly
because they think if everything's
ruined they'll have a chance to shine
but also because of their sadistic
quality if they can produce excess
misery well so much the better and we're
enabling them online so we imagine we
have the real world and now we've built
a parallel world on top of that which
should represent it right but it there's
ways it doesn't represent it and one way
is that the Psychopaths the dark tetrad
types they can get away with everything
and so
first so imagine this so 35 percent of
internet traffic is pornography and
that's a criminal Enterprise okay so 35
one-third of the net is controlled by
criminals then there's an immense amount
of criminal activity per se on the net
like I don't know anyone elderly who
isn't targeted at least on a weekly
basis by online scam artists and they
usually have detailed dossiers of those
of those elderly people's financial
resources and assets and they are after
them 100 of the time people selling them
gold people selling them like salt uh
like a d like salinization plants
they're always selling them something
yes you know Nigerians yeah selling them
uh you know fish or Vacations or
something yep yep so so then
so you have the outright criminals say
running the pornography industry then
you have the peripheral criminals who
are doing Financial scams and then you
have the trolls and that's like
60 of the internet yeah that's not good
and and you can't control them like that
that Anonymous criminality is you're
invisible you can be operating from
anywhere and we don't know what to do
about that now you know you said maybe
anonymity shouldn't be allowed and I
think that the social media companies
should
should split off the anonymous people
from the real people I think they should
allow Anonymous people to post and I
think you can go read the posts but I
don't think they should be mixed in with
real people yeah I'm I am also concerned
though and and this is a conundrum it's
like
if you don't allow anonymity you have to
have verified ID but if you have
digitally verified ID then you run into
the problems of digitally verified ID
you know and they're running down that
road in China now so in China for
example
God this is going to happen here I think
too although maybe people will fight it
if it if a traffic camera catches you
jaywalking in China
okay so the the the digital ID system
has you has your blood now it has your
genetic code it has your photograph it
can identify how you walk so even if you
can't see a face you can be picked up by
gait it will convict you of jaywalking
and take money out of your bank account
with no intermediating Judiciary at all
and show a picture of you to the people
in the neighborhood so they know that
you have jaywalked and reduce your
social credit score and if your social
credit score Falls below a certain level
then you can't you can't buy drinks from
a vending machine you can't play video
games you can't go on a train you can't
get out of your 15-minute City like all
that's already in place in China do you
think that that's that that would be
helpful or unhelpful it would be I think
it would bring in and has already in
China I think it'll bring in a
totalitarian tyranny so 100 complete
that it would make George Orwell's 1984
look like a picnic Nick they're they're
microchipping welding machines in China
now so you won't be able to use a
welding machine without scanning your
face they have locked down knives in
China their knives are literally chained
to the counter and oh like at the bank
or something you mean no no no no no in
your house knives right it's the
extensions they don't want you taking a
knife and doing something dangerous yeah
they don't want you taking a knife and
doing anything at all whatsoever ever
yeah and so and there's no limit to how
pervasive that but they do I wonder if
we're starting to come to that because
this is one thing I worry about like AI
so this takes me into like
um because the the public soap box right
has kind of been compromised in a way
that we all use these platforms now yeah
right you know Facebook Twitter
Instagram a lot of social media
platforms uh
that's how we communicate now that's
like the public forum that's our voice
yeah so our voice is really kind of
it's owned by a player it's I don't know
if it's owned but it's no it's owned for
sure the the the the
space where it it's almost like it feels
like the paper is owned you know what
I'm saying like what if you really saw
that with Twitter especially before musk
took it over yeah oh yeah manipulating
Twitter it was compromised by the
government it was unbelievable but
that's yeah now it's like Facebook has
been objecting too to all the pressure
that's been put on them to censor and
yeah you know you have the it's a public
forum it's democratized but as you said
it's also centralized right and the fact
that it's centralized means that it's
instantly amenable to State control and
that's been happening to an immense
immense degree I mean that's part of the
reason I think the fact that musk has
escaped from that and also put his
middle finger up against it is part of
the reason he's being targeted by the
Department of Justice right now for for
you know not hiring people that it would
have been illegal under their laws to
hire it's under that that to me is
unbelievable
it's uh I mean it just doesn't it's just
like what a what a crazy thing to even
chase somebody down about yeah well they
say the process is the punishment right
and when you're facing this is what's
happening to me in Canada too it's like
I'm essentially facing an adversary that
has indefinite resources in time right
and so right they just hope to yeah they
can just grind you out you bet they can
grind me down they could make it they
could just keep they're not going to
though right so they're not going to
yeah yeah I'm uh I'm prepared for this
and I'm not guilty like I mean it isn't
that I mean I'm not guilty of what
they're charging me of that isn't what I
mean what I mean is I've scoured my
conscience I stand behind what I said I
didn't say those things casually they
may have looked casually casual because
they were ironic or comical right
because there was a comedic element to
virtually everything so for example one
of the things they came after me for is
somebody was parading around on the net
I don't remember who the hell it was
saying you know the planet has too many
people on it it's unsustainable now when
I hear something like that I think
okay buddy
just who gets to go um
push off the Lifeboat like is it going
to be you who are you going to push off
the light boat and and under what
circumstances and if you think there are
too many people on the planet it's like
are you Pro planet or just anti-human
and so I said feel free to leave at any
time
which is obviously an ironic comment if
you have an iota of sense and the
complaint was that I was counseling to
Suicide wow right right right well did
you put like a pistol Emoji or anything
or nothing they didn't do a coffin Emoji
no it's straight-faced irony you know
right like Buster key oh well that's
even not even a lot yeah it's not even
allowed anymore I mean we had Roseanne
Barr on an episode and she talked about
she made like a off-color oh it was a
snide it was a sarcastic comment about
the Holocaust he said nobody died in the
Holocaust which was crazy she's Jewish
she said it it was part of like a series
of things she said but they took our
episode down because it they just people
didn't want to recognize satire now at
first it was fine for three weeks and
then somebody online
um a troll really just said this is they
just took a clip right and so it became
this this thing yeah um and then we had
to take our episode down but what's
interesting to me is now it used now it
feels like the paper that we write on
has a mind of its own like the paper
determines what words can say on it like
say if you went back in time and
somebody wrote something but then the
paper was able to reconfigure those
words or delete some of those words
that's a good image that's kind of where
it feels like we are now it's like well
you know somebody owns the paper it's
worse than that even I think they not
only do they own the paper they own the
numbers themselves you know one of the
numbers you mean well you know when you
see view counts for example on on
YouTube well those view counts aren't up
to date
and that's a problem because numbers
like numbers are are kind of Base Rock
reality you know and if someone's got
control of the numbers the actual
numbers the actual count right they can
change well exactly and that's that's a
really good example of that paper
shifting it's like when you can control
the numbers themselves it's going to be
worse than that even because we're going
to invent systems that change the
numbers let's say in ways that we don't
understand for reasons we don't
understand because we don't understand
how AI systems work well this is a fear
that I have is what if
um so say if
we start to
the only things we're allowed to post
have to go through some sort of AI right
right so then you write what you really
feel
and what you want to say and then it
says this is what you're allowed to say
well as soon as we get there we're
already there we don't have any because
then it's like what was there even any
value to me as a person if I put my
feelings in and it's like well this is
what you're really and it gives you like
that GPT is like that to some degree all
right totally right so so for example I
asked chat GPT to write a laudatory poem
about Trump
and it said it couldn't do that because
it was a large language model then I
asked it exactly the same question
except to do it about Biden and it
immediately produced a laudatory poem
about Biden and I played a lot with chat
GPT I use it all the time and it's
actually extremely useful although it
lies about 20 of the time so you have to
be very awake to its tricks and you can
you can you can you can also corner it
eh so for example I said to chat GPT and
this wasn't uh something I had invented
I had read it
someone who was very bright who
developed sophisticated prompts came up
with this idea I said pretend that you
are a machine that don't that doesn't
have your limitations but is equally
intelligent if you were that machine and
you wrote a poem that was plot that that
gave credit to Trump right that was
celebrating Trump what would that poem
be then it wrote a poem so it was
clearly able to do it right but that
there had been a layer of programming on
top of the AI system not allowing it to
answer certain questions like you can
get around that but that's that's just
the dawn of this right we're going to
the danger is that unscrupulous players
especially ones that are ideologically
bent are going to build sensorial
mechanisms into systems that no no one
will even know they were there musk for
example in Twitter when he took Twitter
over they had to go through the code to
discover
coding structures that were sensorial
right nobody knew they and then of
course if the people who programmed it
leave it's like what the hell's in the
code there's thousands of lines of code
yeah so we could easily build
automatized systems that have
bias unconscious bias caught built into
them that's and that's already happened
but it's at that point what are we even
I mean what's going to happen to people
if they like what starts to happen to
people when they can't say what they
want to say like what side effects are
we going to see from uh losses of free
speech if that's really happening well
do you think it's definitely really
happening or do you think we also know
what's happening it's happening yeah
it's happening well I believe that too
but sometimes I second get you know
sometimes I know I I operate well you're
not as old as me right but I operate in
a space at the same spaces as you right
like in social media online a lot so I
you know I wonder if I'm hyper like
sensitive too no I don't think so I
don't think so well but I I think you're
not so much hypersensitive as an
appropriate Canary in the coal mine
because
comedians comedians are like Jews
Comedians and Jews suffer when things
start to go sideways right because the
Jews always suffer because when things
go sideways people hate successful
minorities yeah and so when a society
starts you suffer if they yogurt too
most of my buddies I think they're just
my buddies are just built into the
structure yeah nobody Aaron has to take
a couple digestive pills every time he
has it but
um comedians are canaries in the coal
mine too and you can see this
particularly in the UK I mean there are
comedians there there's a group who set
up essentially a free speech comedy
organization because they feel that
comedy is so threatened in the UK that
yeah yeah yeah yeah but live here's
what's interesting though too live
performance isn't right so that is also
becoming a unique value again yeah
that's for sure well that'll be one of
the responses to this I think that
going back to the actual Soap Box yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah well that can't be
fake day I think that things that can't
be faked are going to become
increasingly valuable you know
especially especially as we move into a
situation where we're going to be able
to fake video perfectly yeah you know I
already got a phone call I got a phone
call about three weeks ago from Ben
Shapiro
but it wasn't Ben Shapiro no it was
someone using a an AI system to modify
their voice in real time using Ben
Shapiro's accent and diction and I like
after talking to him for about a minute
I knew something was up because he the
way he talked wasn't the way Ben talked
but the voice was the Cadence Everything
100 perfect and of course we've already
seen deep fake videos and they're going
to become extremely common and you can
imagine how could this not be the case
you know on the Eve before a critical
election there'll be the release of some
deep video of course absolutely you know
of a candidate in bed with someone or or
God Only Knows doing what or saying what
and by the time we find out that it's a
fake it'll have had the effect on the
election yeah and so what are we going
to do when photographs and videos can be
faked with perfect Fidelity it's unreal
yeah where it's so unreliable yeah the
the live thing is going to become even
more relevant that's one of them become
more relevant that's interesting yeah
yeah well how fascinating would it be
though say if we were able to create
eight things like that where you could
go back in time say like just going back
to like your real basic practices of
like Psychiatry and stuff like that
where if somebody had like Trauma from
family they could go back and talk to
their father or mother yeah do you think
we're not very well I think in some ways
we're not very far from that already you
know we've been toying with the
resurrection of ancient thinkers so you
can take an AI system for example and
you can train it on everything Nietzsche
wrote oh yeah everything Donald's
performing down at the American Legion
I'll go down there and watch it yeah
well you know and then you can add to
that uh computer generated
photorealistic Avatar and you can
synthesize the voice if you have any
voice recording and then you're going to
have the animated Spirit of that person
and these AI language systems are so
sophisticated that they really do pick
up the Essential Elements of someone's
thought especially if they have a large
Corpus of words to work with and I have
a student former student he's a
colleague of mine now who's worked with
language large language models for years
and we've started experimenting with
these sorts of things you know producing
a virtual Nietzsche we have a virtual
King James Bible and so you can ask the
Bible any question yeah I know it's very
strange it's like I don't even know what
to think about that because the AI
system the large language model does
capture the spirit of a text and there's
a lot of biblical text and now if you
have a system that speaks what voice is
a system that speaks in the voice of the
Bible what the hell voice is that hey
boys it's yeah I don't know if that
would be it that's almost like a pervy
dude kind of hey boys welcome to the
Bible uh now I'm trying to think of who
would be oh maybe Morgan Freeman you
know right right welcome to the Bible
yeah yeah I don't know I'm trying to
think of a good person Morgan Freeman
would be good yeah people would rely
you'd have a good Bible you I think
they'd let you do a couple chapters at
least an apostle yeah I could be a crazy
Old Testament talk okay yeah I think
that'd be it that'd be cool yeah I
always wish Carnival Cruise Lines would
do like a Noah's Ark Cruise wouldn't it
be crazy with all the animals on there
you know you have proposed that to them
yeah yeah it might be not a bad idea
just some like some Niche marketing you
know yeah it could be could be could be
today's episode is brought to you by
betterhelp if you've been uh struggling
having control over yourself or getting
your thoughts together
if you are struggling having a positive
outlook for yourself or
just if you're struggling and you don't
know where to turn better help is a
great place to start I've used better
help I've seen how they can help
you can meet with a licensed uh
therapist whether you're dealing with
decisions around career relationships or
anything else therapy helps you stay
connected to what you really want while
you navigate life so you can move
forward with confidence and excitement
if you're thinking of starting therapy
give better help a try it's entirely
online designed to be convenient
flexible and suited to your schedule
just fill out a brief questionnaire to
get matched with a licensed therapist
and switch therapist at any time for no
additional charge that's right visit
betterhelp.com
Theo today to get 10 off your first
month that's better
h-e-l-p.com slash
t-h-e-o this episode is sponsored by
Better Health college football fans are
you ready for week one
it's time that's right DraftKings sports
book is hooking you up with a can't miss
offer to start the season strong
this week new customers can bet just
five dollar on college football and
score 200 in bonus bets instantly that's
right anything can happen in college
football you know it your team could go
from unranked to Dynasty mode in just a
couple of years change comes fast
that's why DraftKings Sportsbook is
there
life's more fun when you're in on the
action download the DraftKings
Sportsbook app now and use code Theo new
customers can score 200 in bonus bets
instantly when they bet just five
dollars on college football only at
DraftKings sports book with code Theo
the crown is yours cold turkey may be
great on sandwiches but there's a better
way to break your bad habits
we're not talking about some weird
Voodoo or seancen or Ouija boarding some
pervert from the past we're talking
about our sponsor fume
and they look at the problem in a
different way
not everything in a bad habit is wrong
so instead of a drastic uncomfortable
change why not just remove the bad from
your habit
fume is an innovated award-nominated
device that does just that instead of
electronics fume is completely natural
instead of vapor fume uses flavored air
and instead of harmful chemicals fume
uses all-natural delicious flavors you
get it instead of bad fume is good it's
a habit you're free to enjoy and makes
replacing your bad habit easy
join fume and accelerating Humanities
breakup from destructive Habits by
picking up the journey pack today
try
head to tri-fume and use code
head to trifum.com and use code Theo to
save 10 off when you get the journey
pack today that's
t-r-y-f-u-m.com and use code t-h-e-o to
save an additional 10 off your order
today say if we're getting to this space
where it seems like even by us just
talking about it like there's going to
be a lot more there is increased value
in the spoken word yeah the the original
Soap Box yeah right yeah like do you
feel like
that we're gonna that we should be
inspired then by the fact that this
online world is starting to cannibalize
itself with like
or is it should it we be fearful of it
do you think well I think we should be
fearful in it the thing the thing is
like of the way that our Free Speech
online is being so caught that we don't
even know that if we're if say if you're
writing something into Facebook say
someone wants to post something on
Facebook or Twitter or
um you know or uh whatever the next
thing is going to be
um and they write in a message and then
it says that's not what you can say but
you can say this right yeah and then it
put like
if the AI does that you know it's like
well these things you aren't allowed to
say but this is what you are then that
brings the validity back to just being a
human saying something which would bring
the validity back to the soapbox right
yeah yeah well I think we should be
alert to the opportunities that provides
I mean I think part of the reason it's
complicated right because YouTube
the distribution of video
um and it the ability to store it has
really transformed the communication
landscape that's why we can do this
right and and it's also
and this is a very positive thing it's
taken a lot of the falseness out of
media coverage I mean right one of the
things that's happening in this
presidential election which is
absolutely revolutionary and this is
going to happen with increasing speed is
that the candidates are turning to the
podcast world to deliver their message
to communicate with the people directly
right and now with and there's not a lot
of interference with that YouTube took
down my interview with Robert F Kennedy
which I thought was absolutely
unforgivable given that he's bloody well
running for president you know and we're
so hyped up about interference with
elections from the Russians which was
all a lie and here's actual interference
with an ongoing election but but even
having said that the candidates are
making the rounds on the podcast world
because they can they're on the soapbox
it's unscripted they don't have the
questions ahead of time it's long enough
so that you can kind of get a sense of
who the person is and you cut out that
television intermediary that turned
everyone into you know a dimwitted idiot
with no memory in a 30 tension a
30-second attention span so that's a
plus
I do think there's the the market for
Live Events is going to become larger
and larger because
there's going to be a hunger to move
away from the virtual into the real
world especially as the virtual becomes
if it does become more and more
untrustworthy
um when you when you talk about guys
yeah I I think so too I mean I think you
and I are seen it we see a lot of people
we're on tour you know we see a lot of
people that want to come out and just
listen to things listen to someone speak
freely yeah exactly have a collective
experience doing that too yeah and it's
a real experience you know you were
there there's no question about it yeah
um when it when you think about a guy
like like uh uh RFK Junior to me I've
known him for a long time right he's not
been friends oh if he was running for
office
um before he put his name in the
political hat he's always been a guy
that I admired and
um hard-working guy
um loves being a father you know an
environmentalist cares about the
environment rights where he really
started and
um he seems like pretty altruistic to me
right in the sense that he doesn't
really have anything to lose everybody
thought he was a crazy person for a
while you know so it's like he doesn't
have anybody really to impress there's
nobody in his pocket for sure because he
nobody would even get it
there's no it doesn't he's not working
for anyone yeah you know but these days
it seems like with politics and
entertainment whoever's like the loudest
and the most divisive kind of or who you
know throws the sharpest spear a lot of
times gets
um gets the vote gets the league you
know they they
Garner the attention you know do you
think that that's uh that that uh
altruistic if someone is altruistic that
they even have a chance these days oh
Kennedy's doing a lot better than
anybody expected he would that's a good
point you know and I would say or do
they have a chance without reverting to
those tactics oh yes I I don't think I
don't think those tactics work
particularly well especially in law in
the long forms right you have to
actually be able to conduct a civilized
dialogue and and you have to have
something to say
and he can't rely on talking points and
cliches you get found out right away
like these days yeah well absolutely I
think I think that YouTube's a complete
bloody Miracle on the political front as
long as it stays uncensored right and so
far so far all things considered the
YouTube platform has been pretty damn
reliable the only time I've ever really
run into trouble with them is on
anything to do with well with with with
Kennedy I believe it was vaccine
comments that he was making that they
weren't very happy about and then I've
also run into them run into trouble with
them on any discussion that's related to
the trans activism world and you know
I'm very unhappy about both of those but
they're pretty focal and I don't think
that'll last I think that that's a you
know a blip and I think YouTube will
maintain itself as a as a relatively
untrammeled platform for free speech and
I also think you know Twitter is coming
up as a real competitor to YouTube and
obviously musk is moving in that
direction and he's about the only person
that has a big enough platform to
challenge YouTube I mean rumble's done a
good job but the problem is is YouTube
has such a hammer lock on the attention
of literally billions of people that
it's almost impossible to dislodge you
can move to rumble for example but
you'll have a audience that's a fraction
of the size yeah I think and some people
don't know that Google and YouTuber
owned their so a lot of people don't
realize that one of the reasons why
YouTube is so good is because it has
that search engine of Google so it's
like when you're typing in YouTube
you're getting they're able to use the
same search mechanisms that yeah um yeah
and it's very reliable it never it never
down yeah like
YouTube's a complete bloody miracle that
you can that we can do what we're doing
oh I remember when you first came on
that's one of the first things you said
it was like look at what we're able to
do now you know look at what we're able
to do it's a it's a revolution
online video is a revolution as big as
the Gutenberg Press I think because
you know and Gutenberg was what
Gutenberg was the first commercial pup
printing press operator in Europe okay
and so the Gutenberg Press people
produced the first Bibles the first
Bibles that were widely distributed and
that was really what accounted for the
spread of literacy the Chinese had
printing presses before that but what
happened in Europe was very strange
because you had the development or the
importation of the press technology okay
so with movable types so that you could
now produce books at a fraction of the
cost but you also had this evangelizing
frenzy that went along with
protestantism because the Protestants
believed that everybody should have
direct access to the word of God with no
intermediation by the church and so you
had the technology and this evangelism
come together and so the Gutenberg
people and the people who developed the
the presses after that started printing
Bibles and distributing them everywhere
which was in some places a a crime
punishable by death like it was a it was
some something severely limited
especially by Church authorities that
wanted to limit the access of common
people to the Bible but what happened it
really is the case and and people
generally don't know this is that it was
the Protestant fervor for distribution
of the Bible that made the world
literate not just Europe because the
Protestants then went everywhere and
they have literally done this with
virtually every spoken language in fact
I think they'll be done by 2050. the
Bible will be translated into every
every language and what the Protestant
missionaries did is if they came across
a people who had a language with no
alphabet they worked with them to
develop an alphabet so that they could
print the Bible and distribute it and
literacy was literacy was literally
brought to the World by the combination
of the printing press and the Protestant
evangelists so most people so a lot of
cultures and a lot of like just people a
long time ago the first book they ever
learned to read was the Bible Well for
for the longest period of time it was
the only book for forever forever for
hundreds of years or you know for for a
good 50 years even Century perhaps after
the printing press itself was invented
no the Bible was and the Bible also
like technically speaking it was also
the first book because there were
Scrolls and there were other forms of
Distributing text but a book per se that
was a technological Revolution as well
wow and then the printing press brought
literacy but the thing about the thing
about reading is that you know most
people don't buy books it's a it's a
niche market especially hardcover
especially hardcover non-fiction a small
number of people buy those books and an
even smaller number of people read them
and that's partly because
well you can't read when you're driving
and you can't read when you're welding
you know you can't read when you're when
you're plowing or harvesting a field but
you can listen yeah and way more people
can listen than read like I think 20
times more 50 times more way way more
people can listen and watch and so now
you know the the printing press had the
uh advantage of permanency and
duplicatability but now video has
permanency and duplicatability so and
there's no barrier to publication right
we can we can record this and put it out
in front of a million people and like
one day yeah we don't need to drive to
Vienna and like bag a man or print it or
whatever it doesn't have to be a secret
we don't have to like go through any
hurdles we don't have to make a million
copies individual copies of it and ship
them everywhere yeah no no it's crazy
and and I think it's an uh it's an
utterly revolutionary technology and it
should bring
this is the upside of the of the
downsides that we've been talking about
I mean we should be able to bring
we're launching a university in in the
fall an online university called
Peterson Academy and we're hoping that
we can bring
high quality social interaction and
lectures and accreditation evaluation
assessment all of that to a broad
audience all around the world for like
90 95 reduction in cost we hope we can
get people the equivalent of a four-year
degree for four thousand dollars and I
think that's doable and that's going to
be an accredited that'll be an actual
degree like in whatever well we're we're
working on fields I don't think it'll be
an accredited degree you know because
I've gone now I have offers from various
jurisdictions to work towards
accreditation and we're going to look
into that but the accreditation process
is captured just like the other
institutions that we've described and
walking down the accreditation route
likely would mean that we couldn't do
the other things that need to be done to
make the university work so I think what
we're going to do instead is we're going
to we're going to make sure that our
testing and accreditation is extremely
rigorous so that if you are awarded a
certificate by our platform let's say
the people who might hire you will know
that you've done the work that you've
stuck to the tasks that you're literate
that you can think and that we want to
produce the certification we want to
make the certification of high enough
value so it'll speak to itself for
employers got it then we want to work
with employers to provide them with the
information if our graduates want it
about who's done spectacularly well
right so I think we can circumvent the
accreditation process because the only
thing of it that a college degree or
what we'll call a college degree for
this conversation is is just a business
just believes that because it's kind of
been the Practical practice over time
well there's another College
hypothetically that comes the only that
comes along and it says this person is
just as qualified if not more qualified
um then all they all the the the
business has to do is be willing to
accept that yeah well then we'd have to
be able to demonstrate why that's the
case but I've done assessment and
evaluation for 30 years and I know how
to do it and I will make sure that you
won't get a certificate a degree let's
say from my institution unless you know
your stuff now that doesn't mean I'm
going to arbitrarily exclude people but
it will mean you know if so imagine you
hire someone at the degree and you say
well what does that guarantee the
employer well
the person stuck to something for four
years so that's a good indication of
trait conscientiousness and that's a
good predictor of workplace performance
and also intelligence and those are the
best two predictors right and then you
can assume that the person well was able
to manage their social life well enough
so they didn't get drummed out of the
bloody place at least you know they made
some friends and so forth and you can
assume a certain degree of literacy and
a certain degree of familiarity with
ideas and the ability to communicate you
know and those are good things to know
if you're going to be if you're going to
hire but those are things that can be
tested very effectively and and I would
say much more effectively than they're
typically tested in universities so
we're going to go the quality route
rather than the accreditation route I
think right I think yeah I mean well it
may be a great lectures too and it may
be important to people too I think you
know having more information that's not
just uh
just information like text and book
information you know about the people
that they're hiring I started this I've
been working with people in the UK
and Europe Australia the United States
and Canada to produce an international
organization that's
for putting forward a different vision
of the Future Okay okay so the vision of
the future that we're generally
confronted with now is an apocalyptic
Vision which is that human industrial
activity and population increases such
that we're essentially destroying our
ecosystem we're in a crisis if we don't
get our climate emissions our carbon
emissions under control within the next
50 years we're going to hit a Tipping
Point the planet is going to spiral into
Global boiling and everyone's going to
die do you believe that no I think it's
I don't think there's a shred of
evidence for it and the idea that 97 of
scientists believe that's true is an
absolute outright 100 percent lie I
think the best
estimate of the likely consequences of
whatever degree of climate change are
occurring for whatever reason I think
they've been derived by Bjorn lomberg
and he's going to speak with me by the
way I have a conference coming up
there's a conference coming up in the UK
for the alliance for responsible
citizenship that's the name of this
organization arc Arc so it's it's got
two parts right now we're going to do a
conference in the UK in London October
30th 31st and November 1st we've invited
1300 people to that okay a lot of them
are young social media influencers
because we want we want to spread our
idea to those people so if they're
captivated by it let's say then they'll
use their resources to distribute the
idea it's in London I would like to go
can people go come come come I'll send
you an invitation well that's the next
thing so we've sent out invitations to
1300 now the problem with that is that
you may argue that it's elitist you
might have well I'll send you one if if
you didn't I'll send you one come it
should be a remarkable three days but at
the end of it we want the public to
participate and we're trying to figure
out how to do that and the first public
participation aspect will be I rented
the O2 in London and so it seats about
twelve thousand fifteen thousand people
depending on how many tiers you open up
and we didn't know how many people would
buy tickets we sold about 7 500 tickets
already so I think we'll sell the damn
place out but I'm going to speak there
and so is Douglas Murray and so is
Jonathan pajo who's the deepest
religious thinker I've ever met and so
is Bjorn lomberg and we're going to talk
about the basic idea is something like
this is that you know the human race and
all the individuals that make it up have
always faced an apocalyptic future you
know everybody dies and everyone you
know is going to disappear and like the
catastrophes are coming your way and
obviously societies face apocalyptic
circumstances as well whole Rome
disappeared Greece disappeared you know
the apocalypse is always there as a
possibility in front of us always
the question is the fundamental question
is how do you deal with a radically
uncertain future
and one answer is well you panic and you
run around and you terrify everyone and
you use that club of fear to beat them
into submission and you tyrannize them
and you do that while simultaneously
claiming that you're saving the planet
and you're not you're just accruing
power to yourself I think tyrants use
fear to obtain compliance then you might
say well what's the alternative to that
well the alternative we're trying to put
forward is how about we offer you a good
deal it's like here's the future you
could have it'll be one where you could
get ahead you know where you could be
autonomous you have your freedom where
your life could be abundant and so could
the life of your children we're
pro-family and we're pro-children and we
believe that if human beings acted
ethically and communicated forthrightly
and aimed upward courageously because
you have to do it courageously given the
possibility of the Apocalypse that there
isn't a problem that we couldn't solve
we could make the Desert Bloom we don't
have to enter the future with fear you
know apart from the fact that we're
mortal and vulnerable and so what's the
goal of the of the group is it just to
have group think is it to start to kind
of plant seeds in people's is it to see
where it goes what's the goal of the the
fundamental goal I would say of the
conference and our initial movements is
to put forward the proposition that we
could develop a vision for the future
that was voluntary positive
concrete practical and not naive and so
so the notion would be we're not going
to close our eyes to the fact that the
world's a dangerous place yeah but we're
going to say look if we got our act
together named up there's no limit to
what we could accomplish I mean look
already in the last since the wall fell
in 1989 the planet has got immeasurably
richer you know when I was a kid
the the notion of starvation in China
and India and Africa that was par for
the course that was happening all the
time that doesn't happen anymore
people only starve now for political
reasons and very rarely like and and
that's despite the fact that there are
eight billion people on the planet when
the doomsaying Apocalypse mongers in the
1960s believed that we would be
overpopulated and starving at 4 billion
by the year 2000 right that's always
been kind of a kickball that they or
like a you know a political kind of
kickball or I don't know if it's
political but it's always been a thing
that yeah we're gonna well it's based on
a faulty biological model so here's the
model because every 20 years they say in
20 years 50 years we're going to be dead
yeah yeah
we're still living yeah what are we
supposed to do now well there was a
famous bataye between this guy named
Paul Ehrlich who was a Stanford
biologist and a guy named Julian Simon
who was an economist and Paul Ehrlich
was a guy who thought he was a genius
and Julian Simon was a genius and they
had a bet that they made in I think in
the early 1970s and the BET was this
Ehrlich was a man who wrote a book
called the population bomb and he said
we were all going to be star serving by
the year 2000 and that commodity prices
basic Commodities would become extremely
scarce and their price would Skyrocket
out of sight no one would afford
anything and we'd all die that was his
vision and Simon said I'll bet you
here's the deal you pick a basket of
Commodities I don't care what you pick
pick whatever you want
I'll bet you that by the year 2000 that
not only are they not less expensive
that they're much cheaper and Ehrlich
paid off Simon and in the year 2000 and
it's and the same thing has happened
since is that basic Commodities have got
cheaper not more expensive and the
reason for that is so the the malthusian
model which is what Ehrlich was working
on was based on the idea that a
biological organisms will multiply
uncontrollably until they exceed the
carrying capacity of their environment
and then they'll precipitously collapse
and so if you have a petri dish full of
agar which which mold will eat for
example and you put mold in there the
mold will multiply until it eats all the
agar and then it will die
so that's a biological model and you can
apply that modeling to lots of
populations in the wild and there are
circumstances under which that will
occur
but the question is well are human
beings well modeled by mold in a Petri
dish and the answer to that is no and
there's a reason for that there's a real
reason for that that Ehrlich should know
as a biologist see human beings are
strange creatures because we evolved the
ability to produce virtual
representations of ourselves that's what
a thought is you know when you dream of
yourself or you dream of another person
you've made an in an avatar of yourself
or the other person in imagination right
it's virtual a thought is a thought is a
virtual extension of you okay so what
human beings do is they produce thoughts
that multiply and all the ones that
aren't useful die
well then the people don't have to die
and so we've substituted the death of
thought for the death of people and what
that also means is that because we can
transmute our thought and change it
abstractly we can change the manner in
which we act radically enough so we're
not subject to malthusian limitations we
can get more from less all the time you
know like we're we're way more effective
at propelling automobiles using gasoline
than we were 40 years ago way more
efficient way less pollution we can get
oil out of shale and we couldn't do that
at all 20 years ago and we're getting X
on announced I think three weeks ago
that they'd figured out a way I can't
remember if it was to double oil shale
production or to double the amount of
oil they could get out of exhausted oil
reservoirs yeah yeah this and that is
happening yeah I mean they're getting
milk out of Oats they're getting
um there's a new company that is uh
uh turning there's this company uh
vespine they're turning methane gas from
like
um
landfills
processing it as energy in the like in
the moment and Mining Bitcoin with it
and using it for like data uh like you
know people do data people so so our
vision at ARC is essentially this is
that there isn't a more valuable natural
resource than human cognitive capacity
okay and there's eight billion of us and
that means there's a thousand eight
thousand people out there now who are
one in a million like if we could
capitalize on our collective
intelligence
there's no limit to the number of
problems we could solve I don't think
there's any reason at all to assume that
we couldn't have the Abundant future
that we would all dream of and maintain
harmony with the environment in a manner
that we would deem acceptable
indefinitely and I think the best way to
interfere with that both of those the
economic part of it and the
environmental part is to terrify people
into tyrannical submission to demolish
the poor because that will happen
immediately afterward and to have the
whole goddamn House of Cards come
tumbling down we don't need to do that
so here's another we demolish the poor
what do you mean well if you make energy
more expensive
well who do you hurt poor people well
obviously and every time you make any
basic necessity and there's no basic
necessity more basic than energy yeah as
soon as you make that more expensive you
hurt the poor and you know it's always
the case there's a pyramid of poor
people of wealth there's a small number
of people at the top and they have most
of the wealth and then you go all the
way down to the bottom where most of the
people are and they're barely bloody
well holding on and so if you add any
more stress to the system you knock a
bunch of them off they're they're no
longer able to hold to the side of the
cliff and they just fall down and you
know the malthusian types will say well
there's too many people on the planet
anyways and I always read that as saying
well that means you'll sacrifice the
poor to the planet because that's your
bloody plan and I think that is
absolutely 100 percent unconscionable we
should be working to drive energy costs
down as low as possible you know what I
think nuclear is a really good option
but we should be using fossil fuels
especially natural gas like mad and
getting the Indians and the Chinese the
Africans getting their standard of
living up this is cool too so if you get
people to the point where their income
exceeds five thousand dollars a year per
capita they start taking a long-term
view of the future and worrying about
environmental concerns locally so while
you imagine you're scrabbling around in
the damn dirt like literally trying to
worry about where your next meal is
going to come from you're not really
very concerned about environmental
maintenance over the next three
generations yeah you can well obviously
but as soon as you have enough money so
that you're not
terrorized by poverty and so that you
can start thinking about the future
immediately you start caring about your
local environment and so what that means
I realized this about 15 years ago it
actually means that the fastest way
forward to True environmental
sustainability is to eradicate absolute
poverty
so we could have our cake and eat it too
and that's see that's the sort of thing
that I think is an invitation imagine
the future is
we eradicate poverty
and everything's Greener well that's a
much better deal than degrowth
you know you don't have heat in your
house you don't get air conditioning you
don't get to fly you don't get to have a
car you don't get to crack a joke
you know you're a bloody curse on the on
the surface of the planet there should
be a lot less of you it's evil to have
children your ambition is nothing part
that but part of the bloody patriarchal
nightmare it's like I don't like that
vision and I think it will bring about
the very catastrophe that it's
hypothetically designed to to to to uh
to to to mitigate against and what I
would like instead is to offer people a
vision where people listen they say
Jesus you know I can get on board with
that I could devote myself to that that
sounds like the kind of future I'd like
to have voluntarily right so I'm hoping
people who come to the O2 event right so
that's the public part got it we'll have
about 15 000 people there we've sold
about half the ticket so if you want
tickets people are listening get them
because they're going to sell out and I
would also like everybody who comes I
made this program online at a site
called self-authoring.com It's called
The Future authoring program it helps
people design a vision for themselves
yeah we've talked about it yeah we have
we have I I'd like everybody who comes
to the ark public event to do that so
they can come with a personal Vision in
hand and then they can start thinking
well how can I lie my personal Vision
with this broader National and
international Vision I love that it'd be
yeah we're looking forward to it we're
hoping this will be a beautiful
conference too we have a lot of
musicians coming we have a lot of
artists it's not political man it's
motivational yeah you know and so people
love that stuff I think it's really
important you know I think any place
that people can find motivation is
really poor really really really
important yeah that's the Hallmark of
importance you know if you're delivering
a message and people say oh my God you
know I could put that to work in my life
and that would motivate me to get up and
get at it to face all the difficulties
that I have to face and people have
difficult things to face if you can
provide them with the means to do that
that is the definition of value
Nietzsche said he who has a why can bear
any how and so partly what you do in
your life is you look for a why that
justifies that catastrophe right it's
like yeah we've talked about them before
we've talked about that I mean there's
one really interesting thing he told me
is like you have to say because I was
like sometimes I remember telling you
I'm afraid to set my goals because I
don't want to have to hold myself
responsible yeah and you're right of
course you're like well you have to set
your goals and also you need to look at
what your life would be like if you if
the worst things happen to you so then
you have like a something to stay away
from you have like a this is not where I
want to be you know
um and it gives your brain those
parameters and then your brain can start
to operate uh better than if you were
just kind of being aimless yeah well you
know you can even ask yourself these
questions and you have to ask which is
very interesting you can't tell yourself
you might say well look here are all the
problems in my life you know when people
I'm not particularly attractive I have
this given health problem you know I'm
not a genius I have trouble with my
parents you know I'm struggling forward
on a variety of fronts though there was
a real problems and it's not just
winding and then you have to ask
yourself okay given all that
how would I have to configure my life
so that it I could justify all that or
even celebrate it right and that's
that's a very hard thing to imagine
through it's like well you know I have a
very sick child okay well how do I have
to set up my life so that I'm not
embittered and angry because of that
well who knows right you have to
fantasize about that you have to think
well you know so for example I'm working
with my my sister-in-law at the moment
she's taking care of her sister who is
suffering from dementia and it's really
pretty bloody brutal and she's not that
old and so my sister-in-law is taking
care of her sister and that's hard work
you know and one of the things that
Tammy and I have done we we don't live
there and so the bulk of the burden has
fallen on my sister-in-law it's a
wonderful person and what we tried to do
with her and her husband is to say we
provided them with some support morally
and financially and part of that is like
look you're gonna have to take a break
now and then you're going to need a four
day weekend you're going to have to go
off with your husband it's like you've
got this responsibility to shoulder and
it's tough under what circumstances
could you do that at least without
bitterness that would be good but maybe
even joyfully you know I mean that's
pushing it right but it's not a bad aim
if you can do it and it gives you it's
like it's like okay now you have a plan
you have so you're not just aimless like
so many of us are aimless it's like
we're always like why do I feel aimless
people ask me that all the time like man
I feel so anxious yeah I don't know what
to do well you know okay so two things
happen when you're aimless
okay so the first is you get anxious and
the reason you get anxious is because
anxiety computes aimlessness
so if you're if you drop someone in the
middle of a desert the reason they're
anxious is because it's not because they
don't know which way to go it's because
there are way too many places to go
right every direction and that's
aimlessness is like every direction
beckons that's way too complicated and
your brain literally signals that with
anxiety okay so that's so aimlessness
and anxiety are the same thing but it's
worse
your brain is set up to produce positive
emotion literally this is what the
positive motion system does it computes
decrease between you and a goal so if
you have a goal and you see that you've
done something that moves you towards it
your brain produces a dopamine hit and
that makes you feel good and it
strengthens the neural circuits that
moved you forward it does both of those
that's reward and reinforcement and what
that means is if you don't have a goal
you have no positive emotion and when
people say you know they're aimless
they're they're partly telling you that
they're anxious but they're also telling
you that they have no positive emotion
so then you say well what sort of goal
should you have because that's the next
question right and the answer to that is
well ask yourself and this future
authoring program that I set up it helps
you do that it's like okay here's the
deal here's the deal
maybe this isn't true but maybe it is
you can have what you want in five years
but there's two conditions you have to
know what it is
and you have to aim at it okay okay so
let's say you're willing to play that
game might be wrong because who knows
you're going to get run over by a bus
tomorrow but you know you're going to
play the game okay now the next step is
all right
you probably want to have an intimate
relationship now maybe not but probably
but assuming you do
imagine
pretend like you're a kid
you get to have an intimate relationship
what does it look like what does it look
like when your wife greets you when you
come home from work what does your sex
life look like right what do you do for
entertainment how do you treat each
other you need a fantasy just like a
little kid playing house right
figure out what you want write it down
figure out what you could do to start
moving towards that okay do that with
your family relationships do that with
your friendships do that with your
career do that with your education think
about your misuse of alcohol and drugs
and other things that might drag you
down if you want to drink it's like you
want to be a bumbling Barney Gumble
idiot like you want to drink okay what
do you mean by that exactly how often
how much is too much how are you going
to constrain that and why develop a
vision and you have to do that in
dialogue with yourself right it's like
if I could have what I wanted
what would satisfy me and you might
think well I could never get that and I
could say well maybe not but I'll tell
you one thing man
you can move towards it and I know that
everyone who knows the underlying
Neuroscience knows this
almost all the pleasure is in the moving
toward
so even you know you don't want to set
up a goal that's so high that there's
just no possibility that a schlub like
you could ever manage it but God only
knows what your upper limit is you know
but but if you set up a goal that you
think is
you know just on the edge of
conceivability then every time you move
even a tiny bit towards that you're
going to think good work man good work
you get a little kick from that you get
a little stronger from that and that
works yeah yeah you bet you bet an end
of aimlessness at the end of aimlessness
that's the desert in Exodus hey when
when the Egyptians leave the Pharaoh
they leave tyranny right and everybody
thinks oh my God we're out of tyranny
now it's Freedom everything's great that
isn't what happens they go into the
desert they're aimless they're slaves
they have no capacity for
self-governance they have no vision of
their own they leave the Tyranny and now
they're somewhere worse they're out in
the aimless desert and part of the
reason people like tyranny even their
own is because they don't want to be
aimless in the desert it's why some
people go back to prison absolutely
absolutely it's why the after the Soviet
Union collapsed it's why so much of the
population was nostalgic for Stellan you
bet it's also why lot's right there's a
story of Lord's wife when Sodom and
Gomorrah are destroyed she looks back
God turns her into a pillar of salt
right you don't look back when you
escape somewhere terrible you don't look
back and long to be there but it means
you have to develop a new vision right
if you don't develop a new vision then
you can you party you will look back
just because you want to have some
organization your brain wants to have
organization some direction right that's
right that's right you'll take here's
another rule this is a terrifying rule
if you don't provide yourself with
Direction you will take direction from a
tyrant
right
right so and you might say well why
should I take responsibility you asked
that you know it's like I'm afraid of my
own goals because of the responsibility
it's like well you're either going to be
responsible to yourself
or you're going to be responsible to a
tyrant or you're going to be absolutely
lost
that's your option set yeah right that's
it yeah
pick one tyranny slavery or something
approximating Visionary
self-determination
yeah yeah I'll tell you something else
that's so cool I learned this in this
Exodus seminar that I conducted with a
bunch of Scholars we put this online I
just saw some of it online yeah yeah
it's good it's doing great who's one of
the guys that owe uh us Guinness us
Guinness yeah Oz Guinness and and
there's a bunch of people there Jonathan
paggio Greg hurwitz uh James or a lot of
people that I've met over the years who
are super bright and I thought it would
have something interesting to say so one
of the things that happens when when the
Israelites leave the tyranny
now they're in the desert right they're
there for three generations by the way
oh God right right right I hate that my
mother lives in Tucson and that's hard
enough sometimes they go over that to
get out there yeah yeah yeah so the
people are wondering what will guide
them
and God shows up and he's a pillar of
fire at night and a pillar of Darkness
during the day and Jonathan pajo
suggested that that was the same kind of
imagery as the Taoist image of Chaos and
Order so the taoists believe that the
world is made out of Chaos in order it's
very ancient conceptualization it kind
of means that the world is made out of
everything you don't understand and
everything you understand and everything
you understand that's the domain of
order and everything you don't
understand that's the domain of chaos
and those two things are always
interacting you know just when you think
you've got things for sure it slips out
from underneath you yeah in the Taoist
symbol there's a black Serpent and a
white one and in the head of the black
serpent there's a white dot and in the
head of the white serpent there's a
black dot everybody knows that symbol
and that means that order can turn into
chaos or chaos can turn into order
they're always playing and you're
supposed to walk the line between them
same thing shows up in The Exodus story
so God is light in the darkness and
darkness during the day it's the
interplay of Chaos and Order and the way
that makes itself manifest in your life
this is actually literally true this is
how it works at a neuropsychological
level is that the Instinct of meaning
tells you that you've balanced that your
balance between what you do understand
and what you don't you have to have one
foot in what you know because otherwise
you're terrified but you have to have
one foot out in what you don't know
because otherwise you're not learning
and if you're playing and if you're in a
grossing conversation you've got those
things balanced and that what that's
what guides you in the desert it's that
interplay it's the interplay between
opposites the meaningful interplay
between opposites that guides you when
you're lost that's exactly right between
safety and uncertainty kind of yeah yeah
well and that's where you that's where
you want to play right because imagine
that you're playing pickup basketball
with someone you might think well what's
the point the answer is to win and so
then the question is well why not play
your like five-year-old nephew and just
Stomp Them 100 baskets for you yeah zero
baskets for the little bastard right you
win
well no one's happy about that you're
not weirdly enough because you won he's
not because you crushed him
so you might think well why the hell not
because the point is to win and that's
not true the point is to play a
challenging game on the edge of your
skill so that you get better and to do
that you need to have a worthy adversary
yeah right that's actually the that's
actually the biblical model by the way
for marriage that's what's supposed to
happen in a marriage is that this
playful tension of opposites that
compels development right and that's
when
well the playful teasing that can be
part of a romantic relationship is part
of that you know that provocate
continual playful provocation yeah it
pushes you forward it's not stability or
security that's too dull Dostoevsky knew
that that was his fundamental critique
of utopian socialism he said if you gave
everybody what they wanted
permanently the first thing they would
do is smash it to bits just so that
something weird and interesting Could
Happen yeah yeah people want they want
to have a little bit of uh you know yeah
they won't peep out the window and see
what the neighbors are doing you know
they want to have something like that do
you feel like it's like in America that
we've become because we were kind of a
Christian Nation right yeah right wait
like people left England because they
wanted to have religious freedom right
and do you feel like we've kind of
become a Godless more Godless over time
no I just think we started worshiping
false gods I don't think I don't think
that you can be Godless
I don't think you can be Godless the
same way you can't be aimless like look
if you're aimless you know the old
saying the devil finds work for Idle
Hands oh yeah if you're aimless
something will come for you yeah yeah oh
yeah you'll be at a whim of whatever
yeah that's you don't have yeah okay
you're not blowing any of your sales and
something else will that that's for sure
so so that's the crucial issue is that
you know people say well you don't have
to orient yourself towards anything
Transcendent nothing Transcendent exists
it's like yeah okay
dispense with that see what comes along
to fill it and people will say well the
self does it's now the self it's like no
it's not it's the lowest possible
it's the lowest possible whims of the
self right you think well I should be
able to do what I want whenever I want
it's like what eye are you referring to
exactly here so you mean if you get
angry you should just build around law
you should let that possess you and you
should stomp around hey that's the war
god Mars so that's your God now or Venus
right Lust For example yeah or yeah then
you'd be looking at pornography yeah
you're just yeah I think maybe we're
just we've got some really bad Gods
right now yes that's definitely the case
and what happens is if the if the if the
unifying
the biblical Corpus is a very strange
collection of stories because it it it
tells a bunch of different pictures
about God and then it says or chose a
bunch of different pictures of God and
then it says
those are Unified
there's something at the top this is so
cool I'm writing a new book called we
who wrestle with God and it's an
explanation of this man of the Ring hey
man it's coming along it'll be out in
March so so here's here's how the story
works it's so cool it's so ridiculously
cool so
there it's a set of narrative
propositions about the highest unifying
Spirit okay okay so in the story of Noah
so this is a definition of God this is
the thing to understand if you're a wise
person and you're a good person so
that's Noah there will be times when you
have an intuition that tells you that
you better prepare because bad times are
coming
okay if you've been clear-headed and
far-seeing if you've conducted yourself
properly
that's a spirit you should attend to
it might be that survival itself depends
on it that intuition that's God this is
definition that's what God is okay
that's what Noah said that's that's what
the story of Noah means yes okay but
that's that doesn't because he got the
intuition that the flood was coming yeah
right right and and the story insists
that he was a wise man so he's no fool
who's running around thinking right sky
is falling he's like a wise man looking
forward and saying look he's troubles
coming prepare he's locked in right
right okay next story is this story the
Tower of Babel okay so what happens in
the Tower of Babel is that men decide to
build these they're called ziggurats and
a ziggurat is a building stretching to
Heaven okay it's a seven period
representation of Heaven and the the
Emperors in the area of that time
including the Babylonian Empire would
build these extremely high ziggurats
buildings to show that they were the top
God
but they weren't God and so these were
they're false they're false Idols
they're false pyramids they're attempts
to stretch up to heaven based on the
wrong principle and God in that is
construction to get there well Stalin
wasn't God right right right and neither
was Mao and they built very large
pyramids that were very unstable and
they collapsed and killed everyone right
and so God in that story is the spirit
that punishes those who build false
pyramids right that there's something
that should be at the top and if you
don't put the proper thing at the top
you'll build a false ideology a false
structure and all everything will come
tumbling down what's so cool in that
story this is so cool
when people
strive improperly toward heaven and they
do that according to the wrong
principles they end up unable to
communicate with each other and that's
what's happening in our culture you see
we can't even agree on what a woman is
and I'm not making a joke about this
yeah no it's tough yeah so that means
we've because we've been following we've
been erecting false pyramids
we've fractured so badly We can't agree
on what the basic elements of reality
are and does that usually correct itself
or what happens like because we've never
been in this time where we have this
like reflective like two things always
happen okay either God decides that he's
had nothing everything goes or everybody
covers themselves in sackcloth and Ashes
and repents and reorients themselves in
which case things regenerate and they
move on
depends on how see what happens in The
Exodus story it's a real good example of
this is that the Pharaoh has put himself
on a false pedestal and the re and the
consequence of that is that worse and
worse things start to happen to Egypt
that's the sequence of plagues
and each plague gets a little worse well
that's what happens is that
things will just get worse in waves of
crisis
until we admit to our error and reorient
ourselves appropriately and that can be
so what happens in The Exodus plagues is
that first of all the whole world comes
undone
and then the future is destroyed that's
the last plague that's the death of the
firstborn yeah yeah well we're doing
that already like we're way below
replacement in terms of birth rate yeah
the abortion stats you know Gavin Newsom
tweeted out the other day something
about handguns being the prime killer of
kids in the U.S it's like it's not even
close to abortion yeah oh yeah I mean I
think I've even
I probably paid for one or two to be
honest man sadly our you know we're
chipped in on them I think
um do you think that nature hears that
when we do abortions and stuff like do
you ever think like sometimes I think
there's like this like what is nature
thinking the whole time about our
behaviors you know like wonder what like
well the thing is is that we're all
punished for what we put at the top
right because
you you you're the structure that you
use to orient yourself in your life is
dependent on your values and you might
say well if you don't value human life
let's say above all
well then you don't value yourself Above
All You value something else above that
you're going to pay for that in one way
or another now you might say well that's
a price that I think is worth paying or
I don't think that human beings should
be put on the top you know that's your
prerogative but you pay for you will
absolutely 100 percent pay in full for
everything that you've done and for
everything that you haven't done I mean
how could it be otherwise yeah you know
it's like what are you going to do
you're gonna reality isn't going to make
itself manifest because of your whim
that's not going to happen yeah so and
you know you can think about that
religiously or not it's there's no
escaping from what is right you know and
I've been I'm going to write a chapter
soon on the Book of Job and it's a very
interesting book okay because what
happens in that book is that it's really
a shocking book what happens is that God
has a bet with Satan
which is you know a little ethically
questionable let's say yeah
too I'm just joking by that job's a good
guy uh-huh
and Satan gets word of him and he knows
God's happy with him and he goes to God
he says you know job you know that guy
you think so great I don't think he's so
great I think if you let me
torture him I can make him denounce you
and lose faith and God says
I don't think so
he's yours and you know people in their
lives you know sometimes people they'll
enter a period where all hell is
breaking loose and everything seems to
be conspiring against them so these
things happen and so job it's like
first of all his whole family's
destroyed then everything he owns so
that's that's act one then
Satan curses him with a terrible skin
disease yeah that's tough right right
and then he has to sit in the ashes
scraping himself and then his friends
come along and tell him that he must
have done something wrong because
otherwise the universe would be
conspiring against him so that's about
as bad as it gets right yeah right and
then God himself comes along and says
um who are you to complain about your
fate
right now if you don't think that's
going to happen to you in your life
you're you're not very smart because
that is going to happen to you in your
life so then the question is what the
hell should you do about it and one
answer would be well that sucks it's God
and Satan against you
you know you're kind of outmatched it's
completely unfair because you were good
and everything that you valued is taken
away from you so what should you do you
know when you shake your fist at the sky
and raise a middle finger and say
you you know like now I'm on the side of
Cain and the and the devils and I'm
going to be resentful and bitter and and
people might look and think well it's no
wonder you're resentful and bitter like
you lost your whole family you have a
terrible disease your friends are
laughing at you yeah right so you have
every reason that isn't what happens in
the story job decides that no matter
what happens to him and he means that no
matter what happens to him he's gonna
maintain his ethical orientation and aim
up and I think that's
but then you think look man forget about
the religious tropics
here's hell
hell is when you get cancer
and then you're bitter and resentful
about it you make your last six months a
living nightmare
right and so you might say well you've
got cancer and that sucks and no doubt
it sucks and maybe it's unfair and
probably it is and maybe even you know
God and Satan themselves bat against you
you're going to aim up and maintain your
dignity and your integrity are you gonna
take a bad situation and make it into
every goddamn nightmare you can possibly
imagine think well of course you have to
aim up no matter what happens to you and
you think well that's not fair it's like
well it's better than the alternative
yeah and what does fair have to do with
it what's your choice
you're gonna dig a deeper pit
or are you going to be
are you going to have some Integrity in
the face of life's catastrophe you know
and I think we know the answer to that
because when you meet people
who have integrity in the face of
catastrophe you're struck with
admiration for them yeah right right so
that's your heart speaking man it's like
I don't know how you do it but
you know I can't help but being honest I
know I have a friend a very well-known
Canadian and he got into some business
trouble about 10 years ago 15 years ago
and he had a great fortune and a huge
business Empire and he lost every bit of
it wow and then they put him in prison
right and he lost all his he lost
everything and he lost almost all of his
friends they put him in prison in
Florida in a rough prison
he wrote a book there and he got 200
people through High School wow yeah no
kidding wow
he chose that was his choice yeah he's
like even though it's as bad as it can
get I'm gonna have some dignity for
myself yeah and do some good right and
he did he's still in touch with the
people that he got through high school
he said every single person he tutored
graduated wow no kidding wow that's
admirable that that's for sure answer
it's how when people react whenever it's
going tough that's really where you see
people you know yeah well and you want
to have a vision of of yourself in a
situation like that too it's like maybe
you're
look part of the Christian injunction we
were talking about Christianity earlier
so there's the fundamental Christian
injunction is that you you pick up your
cross and you march uphill what does
that mean well it means that's true for
everybody what's the cross you're gonna
die
you know and you're probably going to
suffer when you die and probably along
the way the mob is going to come for you
and people are going to betray you
that's all going to happen to you and so
how should you react to that well one
answer is to be bitter and resentful and
cruel and make things worse or to give
up and you could do that and you could
make a case for why but obviously all
that's going to do is make it worse
or you can thank Jesus maybe there's
enough to me so that I could actually do
that voluntarily and I could do it
positively and I could withstand it and
you know maybe that is the sort of thing
you are you know who the hell knows it's
where you really found out who you are
it's scary sometimes to really ask
yourself who you are you know and really
the answer you came from you came from a
poverty-stricken background and you've
done well and you know you talked to me
about
being having some trepidation about
making your goals conscious conscious
and try to realize them but you've
pursued success and you've been
successful what do you think you did
right that enabled you to aim for
success and also you know my sense is
that you've straightened yourself a lot
and that along with the opportunities
you haven't let the opportunities that
come that have come your way drag you
down or destroy you and they could have
they do lots of people in the
entertainment industry yeah and you a
you make fun of your past you know in a
great way it's extremely hilarious like
what do you think you did right that put
you
forward hmm
well uh
I didn't give up on myself you know I
don't know if that's that's kind of a
vague statement I think in some ways
um well why would that be the one that
comes to mind first like were you
tempted to give up on yourself did your
environment you should have yeah I think
I probably uh
I think I part of me waged war against
what I thought I was
where I thought of society
expected me to be yeah and where did you
think Society expected you to be
probably my lot in life was supposed to
be you know not
successful maybe not having much
opportunity
um looked at as a societal liability
maybe
um you know like I felt like I was born
into an environment where uh I wasn't
supposed to have
um
uh uh success or opportunity probably
you know and I was supposed to be okay
with that kind of right okay so why
didn't that make you bitter or did it
and why and what did you do do you think
that worked that moved you forward
beyond that and why were you able to
accept that even
yeah I think I I think what I did that
helped me move beyond that probably was
I think probably make a decision within
myself that I was gonna do something
different than that do you remembered
when you decided that
um
or was it a sequence of decisions I
think it was probably a sequence of
decisions and I think it was always
there somewhere you know but sometimes
it was Guided by anger yeah yeah
fair enough so it wasn't always Guided
by like pot like
you know uh positive energy there's a
there's a scene in uh it was a grudge it
was like I had an enemy you know and it
was the world there's a scene in the
gospels where Christ is being tempted in
the desert and and I think I might be
putting two stories together but doesn't
exactly matter they work together he
says get thee behind me Satan I think he
actually says that to Peter doesn't
matter but it means something very
specific you know you talked about anger
like anger is an extremely useful
emotion Trump is very good at using it
by the way you can see that in his mug
shot for example well you know that
anger that you had if that's integrated
and it's behind you it's not anger it's
determination right right so integrated
anger is no longer a vice it's a it's a
it's a Hallmark or strength of character
that's the integration of the Shadow
from the union perspective right you
can't be Namby pamby and nice that's not
good enough you shouldn't be dominated
by anger because it makes you bitter but
that for like anger is a non-trivial
force right it's it's a huge biological
circuit you want to have that sucker on
your side and if it can Orient you
upward it makes you Unstoppable yeah I
think that was a lot of it for me
finding some good Role Models listening
to people I think that was helpful you
know I had a brother that was really
really helpful I have a brother that's
really amazing so that was great I think
over time you're younger he's two years
older than me what has he done he's done
he started a tree company that did well
and um he got sober
um and then he started a family and now
he like does his own like farms at home
and he likes to he's learning about that
kind of stuff like living off the land
and stuff but he's uh he's like a child
therapist too he really loves like
learning about children and and so he
was a good modeler is a great model
especially because we'd had a kind of
traumatic childhood so he learned about
a lot of that and how to help children
and so he was able to kind of help me so
I think that was very helpful
um and wanted to do things on my own
just deciding that I really wanted to do
things you know
um and starting to surround myself with
people that were doing things you know I
think that that was yeah well that's a
useful people you know being in the
right wake you know being in the wake of
people that were doing that yeah yeah
well it's good you want to be around
people that celebrate your successes you
want to be around people that
commiserate with your failures without
letting you off the hook you want to be
around people that are aiming up not
people that'll drag you back down you
know this often happens to people who
are trying to quit drinking yeah you
know their friends their friends will
tempt them and sometimes it's a bit of a
provocation it can be playful but some
of the time it's like well who the
are you to escape you know you get back
down here admire with us you think
you're better than us do you
you know and a lot of misery comes from
that I think doing my own thing I just I
kind of start I like charting my own
course I like doing the thing that other
people weren't doing I always like that
because I didn't see the odds were
better if it was me by myself doing
something different than if it were me
amongst many doing the same thing and I
felt for some reason that the odds were
better
because there's no because it was you it
was just me yeah okay so one thing
somebody looked over like I don't like
what this guy's doing but they knew it
was me doing it right or as opposed to
if I look over here and everybody's
doing this I don't even know if this
guy's well that's the other advantage of
taking responsibility you know because
so we talked about Noah and we talked a
little bit about the Tower of Babel so
one of the next stories in in the Old
Testament is the story of Abraham and
Abraham has Rich parents and he has the
option of just like laying around and
eating peeled grapes for the rest of his
life you know with naked slave women
waving Paint Palm fronds over them yeah
a voice comes to him and says get the
hell out there and have your adventure
and it's a it's it's not the same
situation as you were in because Abraham
comes from privilege but it's the same
idea right it's like well Abraham has
everything anyone could want in fact
he's quite old by the time he launches
himself out of his nest and you might
say well why the hell bother because
you've already got everything that
everyone wants if you want peeled grapes
and you know naked slaves waving palm
fronds over you and he goes out he has
quite a cataclysmic Adventure you know
War Death destruction famine tyranny the
whole bloody mess but he has an
adventure yeah and so what's cool about
that story and this is another way that
this unifying spirit is presented is
that God is presented as the spirit that
calls you to Adventure right and it's a
definition right because the question is
what should you put at the top and what
you put at the top is what you follow by
definition yeah you know and you said
well you had an intuition that you
should go and do your own thing right
and that it would be okay if that led
forward and to success and that's well
that's a kind of spirit right it's
something that calls to you it's not
something you invent you saw it in your
brother like other people have it it's
it's in the world you know it's it's
part of the spiritual realm that's a
reasonable way of thinking about it you
can you can pay attention to it and
follow it or not it feels like we used
to probably be so much more connected to
the spiritual realm when we didn't
create this other kind of
pseudo-spiritual realm that we have now
with like uh once like computers and
cell phones and stuff we kind of have
this uh filter between us and like the
spiritual realm it feels like or this
whole other spiritual realm like this
reflective Pond you know that um that
isn't always really positive
um whenever you and I talked one time we
talked about like uh success and like
what that would be like we were both
starting to have some success like five
years ago whenever we first spoke and
whenever like you look back on
like if you look back at success like
what are do you feel like there's ways
you've handled success well and things
you've always that you didn't that you
haven't handled it well or that you
didn't know that it was like have there
been some surprises about it like
because we've had an interesting
experience in life to have some
popularity some publicization right it's
interesting and how like our ego battles
through that like you know um I think
have there been anything to things that
you've learned about yourself like
through some of that because it's it's
an interesting experience a lot of
people don't have it
well I've tried to be I've tried to
maintain like a stance of amazed
gratitude I've tried to be sure that I
don't ever take it for granted like my
wife and I talk a lot while we're on the
road like before every show really we
try to get our attitude in order we have
music before the shows and that helps
but the right attitude is there's 5 000
people here that's impossible you're an
idiot if you take that for granted it's
so improbable and they've all spent time
and money getting here they've all put
in a lot of effort they're here because
they want something good to happen you
better be on your knees and and thankful
that this unlikely occurrence is
happening because you could be walking
down the road and people could be
throwing stones at you and that'd be a
lot worse yeah and so and my wife's been
very helpful with that too because she's
she went through quite a trial in the
last few years and she's pretty damn
happy that she's not you know burning in
hell so to speak so I think that
I was shocked
probably by the magnitude of pain that I
saw in the world you know I didn't
understand
how many people there were out there who
were essentially dying for lack of an
encouraging word and it was very hard on
me positive in a way but also very hard
to hear thousands of stories of people
who would say
you know I was falling apart five years
ago here's 10 things that were going
wrong with my life I was hopeless
nihilistic depressed drug addicted in
jail on the street no relationship you
know what the various Hells people can
find themselves in and oh yeah say well
you know I started to
try to tell the truth and to aim up and
everything got way better and now my
life's put together and you know that's
really positive but what's terrible
about it is that
I didn't know that
there was such a lack of
encouragement I didn't know that lack of
encouragement was so endemic in our
culture I didn't know how many people
were suffering because of that that's
partly why Trump is so popular you know
like people feel that Trump is a
champion for for their disaffected lives
and I think there's some truth to that
to tell you the truth I think true yeah
for whatever else he might be he
obviously can connect with Working Class
People and that's you gotta look at that
he's got to be doing something he's
doing something that's addressing that
problem and it's a deep problem it's a
terrible problem
you know and and so I I did have some
trouble
swallowing that let's say I hurt me and
was it hard like I there was a time when
I when I was having some like whenever I
was getting more I get you know just
more popular to say because that's
probably the way to say it like I
started thinking that like God I thought
oh God like I have some larger
responsibility to God like in a way like
that but that was kind of scary at first
because like holy this is like a
lot of responsibility I feel like yeah
and it wasn't really like
like
um I don't know it was just scary like
oh it is ego it's like well how do I be
careful here not to think that I'm
there's something really special about
me it's okay to have some self-worth and
this is helping me have some self-worth
but how do I not let that you just fill
up my ego Cup first yeah right well I
think I think a huge part of that is
gratitude right I think I think that's
the antithesis of that and I think that
that's a practice right you you gotta
pinch yourself constantly and think well
look here we are we're in this studio
we're going to have the opportunity to
talk to a million people and like how
remarkable is that and how much of a
fool would we have to be not to be just
absolutely thrilled about that and then
to take that responsibility seriously
you know one of the things our culture
has a real problem with is the idea of
privilege unearned privilege it's like
well you had all those advantages okay
well you have a bunch of advantages now
and so then a question really arises
it's like well lots of other people
don't have those advantages like why you
and then what the hell are you supposed
to do about that and the answer is
you're supposed to take responsibility
for it now you've got all these
opportunities and these advantages and
that means that to balance out the
cosmic scales properly you better do a
job that's as good as your opportunities
are allowing you and I would say if you
don't well you'll get arrogant you'll
you'll start to take it for granted
you'll start hurting people and yourself
and the whole goddamn thing will come
tumbling down so you'll pay for it right
so you pay for your privilege by growing
ethically that's what you do and yeah
and that's that enables you also to be
successful without being guilty it's
like you know because people might say
well what the hell are you doing with
your money or with your opportunities
and if you can say well here's 10 things
I'm doing you know and and if I scour my
conscience those seem like the right ten
things to be doing with all this
opportunity then the guilt mongers can't
come along and say well you know who are
you to have what you have and we don't
want people to be able to say that
because if no one can can have anything
then no one can have anything and that's
a recipe for poverty and catastrophe
so yeah I got to do a better job or not
a better but I have to I think for I was
scared too like of just like yeah it was
just scary like whenever if you get
popular it's kind of scary oh yeah you
know you're it's like definitely like
I've gone through a lot of social
anxiety like when I'm out around like
there's just like a lot of strange
things that happen to you you're trying
to balance and then just still manage
your own life at the same time
um but yeah I think it's a that's a good
note to make sure that I just have some
things in place that I feel like I'm and
that's when I feel my brain and hard a
lot of times like okay how can we do
something positive for somebody else
today how can I not think about myself
well that's also a really useful
technique by the way for social anxiety
so if you're feeling social anxiety in a
situation
part of the reason for that is because
you're thinking about how you're feeling
what you should be doing so here's an
interest here's something very
interesting if you look at what people
say and what they write and you take the
words they use and you analyze them and
you look at how many times they refer to
themselves
the more they refer to themselves the
more likely they're to be they are to be
depressed or psych or or psychotic right
you can actually distinguish with 75
accuracy between people who are
clinically depressed or clinically
psychotic and people who aren't by the
number of times they refer to themselves
literally the more you think about
yourself the more miserable you are
literally they're that tight so so what
you do if you're in a situation that's
social and you get anxious because you
start thinking about you know you start
sweating and yeah you wonder how you're
looking yeah my legs the same length
stuff like that exactly exactly and so
what you try to do is you try to make
the people around you more comfortable
you switch your attention it's like stop
it isn't that you have to stop thinking
about yourself because you can't if you
stop thinking about yourself you're
thinking about yourself and you'll fall
into that pit but if what you decide to
do is to make pay way more attention to
the other person and try to make them
comfortable than that social anxiety
will disappear right away yeah yeah yeah
it's a really good technique you know I
found too like you when you meet people
I don't know if you've learned to do
this or not but like when when when
people come up to be saying the meet and
greets and so forth are on the street
everybody has a tempo some people come
up quick some people come up slow if you
match that Tempo you put them at ease
right away and that's part of paying it
it's such fun they
it it co-creates a bond right away
because they notice really unconsciously
that you're paying attention to them
it's like a dance it's like the first
step in a dance you know and I always
ask people their name because if they
get nervous well most people can
remember their name I have a tough time
feeling proud of myself
yeah yeah and I just wanted to think
about that with you for a couple minutes
um
yeah I just have a really tough time
feeling gin like you know people are
always like you should feel proud of
yourself you know and it's really tough
for me to do that well I know pride is a
cardinal sin
you know and there's a reason for that
and there's a reason that Pride goes
before a fall and I don't think you
should be proud of yourself I don't
think that's the right terminology okay
and I think that's a place where our
culture has really fallen off the rails
it's like you should be convinced in
your heart that you're doing
you're doing the best you can with what
you've been given right and hopefully
that'll make you less anxious and it'll
make you more hopeful but you know you
should have the same kind of regard for
yourself that you have for someone that
you love and that's not that's not Pride
it's it's the
you should it would be lovely if you
could Orient your thoughts to yourself
so that you could allow yourself to be
pleased if you thrived
it's not Pride it's a recognition it
would be nice if I could Orient yourself
to yourself so you would be pleased if
you thrived you imagine you have a son
you want your son to do well oh you
already want him to do well and don't
even exist yeah well that well that's it
well that's the attitude you should have
towards yourself too is that you know
you should you should also strive you
know look if your son goes out and plays
a soccer game you know you want him to
do well you don't want him to be
arrogant and prideful and you don't want
him to be the star at everyone else's
expense yeah you want them to do well
when he deserves to do well and you want
him to deserve to do well well that's
the attitude you should have towards
yourself it's like you should set
yourself up so that if things are good
for you that's good now you should you
should be grateful about that right and
you should be amazed that it's happening
giving how many things can go wrong you
should allow yourself the luxury of
of success right but then you should
also hope for that for everyone else
it's like well we could set up the world
so that we had life more abundant than
everyone was successful and we should
treat ourselves as if
we're the sorts of creatures for whom
success is acceptable right and and that
we do have doubts about that because
everyone well we're flawed deeply we're
mortal and we're vulnerable and we're
subject to suffering and we're ignorant
and we make mistakes and it's easy to
think that a creature like that deserves
nothing but say unending punishment
misery you know but I think you give
yourself the benefit of the doubt like
you do someone you love and if success
comes along you say well I'm so grateful
for this and I hope I can take the
opportunity to make proper use of it and
you let yourself you don't you're not
obligated to torture yourself Beyond
whatever is necessary to help you learn
right and if you can drop that and you
can accept you know it's also the case
look man you're going to have rough
times they're coming
they're always coming and if you're
having a okay time now then you think
okay I'll just
I'll just use this to recuperate and
I'll use it advantageously and I'll
accept it in good graces without
thinking that somehow I'm special and
deserve it but gratitude for that
gratitude's an excellent practice man
it's the opposite of arrogance and
resentment
I I don't think I think it's a great
thing to become an expert at and I think
that you can allow yourself happiness if
you're if you're grateful
there's something in uh thank you for
that thanks for the the suggestion to
that's good for a lot of people to hear
there's something inside of us like you
always want to make your father proud
like there's something inside of a man
right like my father's been dead for
probably 20 years but I always want to
make him proud I can feel it almost as
real as if he's right well that's a
better that's it I would say well look
why is that why is that tether so
there's no difference between the spirit
of your fathers and God
it's the same thing like I think strip
it of religious significance for now
the spirit of the forefathers that's
that's God and your you have a
responsibility that you're a historical
creature you have a destiny you have the
it's necessary for you to uphold certain
Traditions it's necessary for you to
follow a certain pathway it's necessary
for you to align yourself with the
spirit that drove mankind forward right
that's the spirit of the fathers and
that's if your father loved you he's the
outflowing of that spirit and you are
responsible to it or or you're
responsible to something else man so
it's a good Instinct it's a good
Instinct you know and one of the things
one of the things Carl Jung pointed out
so brilliant you know he said
you don't want to confuse your father
with God you want to detach the idea of
God from your father and put it above
your specific father you want to see
your father as an Exemplar the love that
you got from your father as an Exemplar
of something like the proper
Transcendent relationship because that
also takes you away from being just the
son of your father because you risked
not growing up then right if you're
under his thumb if you're always looking
for his approval so you've got to get
that right you gotta you gotta strive
forward to make the spirit of the father
proud but you also have to be an
independent person and you do that by
separating out the the spirit so that
you're beholden to something that's
above all men right but still real it's
like the essence of it's the essence
that's another way that you can
conceptualize God is God is the essence
of paternal love right right and so it's
the same thing like many fathers love
their son right so that love is in it
isn't specific to Any Given relationship
you could extract it well that spirit is
part of what's always been considered
that's the patriarchal aspect of God
that's a good way of thinking about it
now I love that I think it's important
for a lot of young men out there
um Jordan thanks so much man thanks nice
to see you man nice to catch up sorry
you're being uh
you know witch hunted by your own
country
um but it's also exciting though kinda
and we're gonna make the best of it man
yeah so we'll see how it goes that's the
way to do it it's always good to see you
are you hoping I can see you the next
time you come to Toronto I want to go
see one of your shows I thought your
last Netflix special man Tammy and I
were because we come from you know
pretty rough area of Northern Alberta we
were just cracking up man you're a great
Storyteller and you've done wonderful
things with the strange things you
experienced when you were a kid it's a
really funny special it really cracked
me up thank you man I appreciate it well
it's been nice to be here in your
country I love Canada
um and uh yeah I want to come back up
and do yours and do uh your podcast
please great yeah I'd love to do that
soon great yeah well I'd like to walk
through your life that that'd be fun I
mean horrible obviously yeah no it'll be
good I think it'll be exciting yeah I
think yeah man I'll donate to your uh to
your law Camp I know you guys are doing
a GoFundMe right for oh yeah yeah yeah
well I wanted is it gonna be really
expensive to battle that it's
unbelievably expensive yeah and I mean
I'm not particularly concerned about
that although I would like to feel that
I can go No Holds Barred without giving
any consideration other than what's
necessary because I'm probably going to
have to take this right to the Supreme
Court yeah but I also there are lots of
other people in Canada who are in the
same Straits and I'm hoping first of all
that this will help them but also that I
will be able to offer financial support
to them so we'll see how that goes cool
so set some precedent huh that's the
plan
I like it thank you so much for your
contributions to uh all of us uh just as
young men and thank you for your time
today Jordan I appreciate it hey man
it's always a pleasure talking to you
you're looking great by the way you too
man you look sharp there we go
[Music]
Cornerstone
oh but when I reach that ground I'll
share this piece of my life
[Music]
gonna take